[Musique]
alors
ça tourne au nom d'un côté une valeur
théorique de quoi la radio ou à la télé
les journaux tout le monde enfin à
l'autre mais oui ce matin chez lui au
précis m'attends à tout moment pas à
l'autre c'est foutu c'est que gilles
trois corps en ligne laon aventure mais
aussi on parle si l'on veut dire que
tout le monde
même si les loups et vise actuellement
d'en bas
quoi
[Musique]
avec thierry ardisson
wauquiez
allez
ça
et vite
l'enjeu
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
et un public
la vision
plus l'été star du soir alain prost
elisa tovati
jo reste là
madame de la vendée
tik tok
en soi les autres plats
hélas boguey
et alexandre les leurs
sylvain gil
avenue sur le plateau de tout le monde
en parle émission pas du tout comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe oscillant la
vie
tu as ultimate enfin johnson de vous
aurais tu es toi aussi avec toi laurent
bonsoir on s'en tirer est ce que vous
connaissez la nouvelle mascotte de
l'émission attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment s'appelle on sait pas comment il
s'appelle comment ils s'appellent ben
voilà nous envoyer les mails et vous
nous dites comment il s'appelle il sa
part
est un peu gonflant clément laurent oui
thierry on commence avec l'actualité et
les ravages du baasisme dans notre pays
les progrès des bâtisses mais tout
d'abord le désarroi de christophe de
lyon qui dit j'ai un gros problème je
suis anti baptiste mais ma [__] et ben
fist
elle bouge pendant le single
under cover
voilà le petit garçon même détresse même
détresse laurent chez sami de bruxelles
qui dit je suis triste j'ai perdu
beaucoup d'amis pour ça ma famille m'a
renier je voudrais que les personnes qui
se retrouvent face à cette situation ne
se sentent pas seuls et sache que
d'autres vivent cela de nice ali ou de
cergy j'en ai marre que mon fils étienne
de trois ans répète charente fois par
jour on ne bouge pas pendant le défilé
est ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose
pour le déjà ne plus appeler un enfant
de 3 ans etienne
voilà et alors beaucoup de mails aussi
laurent concernant votre pièce de
théâtre sexe magouille et culture
générale au théâtre de la renaissance on
ne dira jamais assez beaucoup du mal qui
demande à quand une tournée en province
alors justement la date on été fixé hier
soir logiquement ce serait en janvier
2003 ah bon ouais plus ou alors moi j'ai
une idée pour bien faire chier laurent
baffie amis antibes a fist aller voir
sexe magouille et culture générale et
obliger laurent baffie a joué cette
pièce pendant les 20 prochaines années
voilà
bon ben voilà la mission dans cette
émission c'est de regarder chaque
semaine les meilleurs moments de
l'émission précédente ça s'appelle tout
le monde en a parlé et s'est préparé par
jean luc noël magnéto serge
du samedi soir
tant que les téléspectateurs vous
veulent vous restez est le jouet
nouvelle plus vous parti c'est
exactement
bravo non
on
vous êtes gros lolos
bas pendant ce moment dans le gros lot
je pense qu'il faut la refaire
est ce que vous êtes trop quo
c'est-à-dire comparaison avec freddy
malheureusement d'entre
vous êtes chamallows
alors chamallows expliquez-moi
okuyama les oyats paille a pas
d'intermédiaire
mais là c'est un champion
préférez une femme comprend sans la
comprendre où une femme qu'on comprend
sans la prendre 5 on comprend déjà c'est
héroïque dont que reste acheteur en
réalité
est-ce que se faire sucer c'est tromper
oh non
et alors vous dites si je le trouve au
lit avec une autre jeu l'assassinent
ouais ouais j'suis un peu comme une fois
je suis fait un bleu puis voilà des fois
un chien
non je suis pas aussi jaloux ce que ça
si vous trouvez lui avec un mec là je
rentre dans l'émission
première infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant justement
c'était à mes 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même tonneau
mais je les sentais que c'était ma
dirais trop satana je savais pas
heureusement donc ça va gérer ce
week-end
vous êtes intéressés olivier de
kersauson par les photos de eve angeli
dans fhm non mais leçons ça parle de
l'assemblée c'est bien fermé ses cafés
ses belles photos 1
vous partez avec non non non non je vais
renom non mais je te soir ça peut vous
aider en même temps
sont très très esthétique très pudique
ça sent pas la photo est habituel que
ou même que le brasseur un jour comme ça
vous trouvez en face maintenant ce qu'on
appelait les fellaghas à l'époque et il
va dégainer vous dégainez avant lui vous
le tuez
exact
toute ma vie vous regretterez de ne pas
avoir eu la culture politique d'être un
objecteur de conscience est vrai
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi en vente dans un
magazine et vous soyez quoi comme objet
d'un préservatif mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que c'est exactement la
même chose que l'émetteur on sait les
préservatifs ça rassure quand on en a
mais quand il y en a pas qu'est ce que
c'est bon
est ce que vous êtes trios n'ont pas
papa phallus oui c'est arrivé mais bon
je suis pas là en ce moment je suis pas
trio quoi
la question
j'ai bien un mec vous ayez compris que
tous vos questions à la con vous les
garder pour le côté
c'est le destin
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean est
or vous savez que ce soir à la fin de
l'émission comme kate moss mad leur un
blind test il est consacré aux héroïnes
de la chanson pour arbitrer ce blind
test accompagné par dahlia titia tallio
this you j'accueille massue à philippe
corti
oh honey
[Musique]
très bien alors un petit peu de temps
d'exposition médiatique
rami taleo efficio donc les
téléspectateurs puissent les regards des
juges et jusqu'à présent et vous adore
les mecs pas trop mais les gonzesses
disent que c'est une très bonne idée
comme quoi alors finir comment ça va bon
ça va très bien ouais ça va très très
bien à part que bien c'est le barnum là
bientôt il y aura les enfants des autres
nous les en france que bien sûr les des
gens réclament des enfants des unions
des chiens c'est la panda absolument
philippe alors le jeu idiot ce soir
c'est la pétanque 1 là et voilà alors
vous savez ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là
on fait didier
très bien on peu d'ambiance voilà voilà
voilà et puis une petite musique didier
aussi
innovatrice issue anti siam et les
messieurs ouidah
elle est magnifique et à demeurer lieu
ces princes carrasso mais on frotte à
sanaa
pourquoi vous l'heure est venue
pour le reste place
attention attention si le parti se
détend
attention monsieur
déjà bravo soutien prévues ci ça y est
je suis
dans tous les autres pays du monde mais
georges issiar dia yens
[Musique]
alors vous savez les messieurs que pour
jouer au blind test sans entendre le
samedi il suffit d'avoir un doigt une
oreille et un téléphone cette semaine il
y avait dix cdd stone a gagné et le
gagnant est joël le floch de poullaouen
finistère et la semaine prochaine il ya
un coffret de trente deux cd d'aznavour
à gagner pas mal hein voilà et 50e
double cd collector legend de bob marley
franchement c'est pas de la merde voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant on joue
je cours je me sens tout
voici alain prost
post1 france bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle pour vous exprimer le 22
novembre 2001 l'écurie de formule-1
prost grand prix était mise en
redressement judiciaire pour des dettes
estimées à 35 millions d'euros le 28
janvier 2002 faute d'avoir pu trouver
une solution la liquidation judiciaire a
été prononcée
et hier vendredi 8 février 2002 usine de
guyancourt été fermés l' aventure aura
duré cinq ans presque jour pour jour
alain prost vous allez nous expliquer
vous allez vous expliquer
le 28 janvier après la prononciation de
la liquidation judiciaire par le
tribunal de commerce de versailles vous
avez quitté la salle pour aller dans une
pièce adjacente pour informer en premier
et en audio conférence les salariés de
votre entreprise de guyancourt puis vous
les avez rejoint sur place
et puis cette semaine vous avez fermé
lusine j'imagine à la preuve que votre
première préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est
les 195 personnes qui se retrouvent sur
le carreau
oui aujourd'hui comme comme pratiquement
depuis depuis quatre ans la première
préoccupation ça a été pour eux les
négociations d'ailleurs qui ont eu lieu
avec certains repreneurs ou
investisseurs potentiels on était
toujours dans le cadre de 2,2 de 10
rebonds même si je suis pas là il faut
absolument sauver l'équipe ne serait ce
que pour eux de toute façon si cette
équipe avait durer et perdurer on aurait
vu que les résultats aurait été de toute
façon deux meilleurs puisque tout le
travail qui a été accompli depuis quatre
ans faut bien que ça porte ses fruits un
jour par les conséquences de cette
décision du tribunal de commerce c'est
que dans les semaines qui viennent votre
écurie sera mise aux enchères vous
possédez encore 51 3% du capital il y
aura pas de bleus à melbourne le 3 mars
et pourtant vous avez déjà acquittée 296
1000 euros de droit d'inscription pour
la saison 2002 qui sont pas
remboursables en fait on est en train de
décapiter les autorités c'est peut-être
s'arranger parce que c'est c'est la
première fois que cette situation existe
en formule 1 pourrait compter sur la
redistribution des droits télé qui sont
de 15 millions d'euros non ils sont là
que si on performe c'est dire si on est
dès le premier grand prix a même bon
donc donc le pactole de 15 milliards
d'euros sera partagée entre les
différentes écuries restent quoi
exactement d'où leur empressement de
nous aider
alors voilà on va parler maintenant de
l'histoire de l'écurie prost grand prix
des causes de cette situation alors
l'impro c'est bientôt 47 ans vous êtes
né en 1955 à lorette dans la loire
enfance à saint chamond le pays
d'antoine pinay votre père et votre mère
travailler ensemble dans la confection
de meubles et des parties métalliques
pour des chaises et des tables votre
mère est d'origine arménienne sa famille
est arrivé en france en 1920
vous vérité quoi d'elle
je pense de cette ténacité
eh ouais en fin de compte on se laisse
jamais abattre même si de temps en temps
sur la figure on va aider très mais j'ai
au fond deux enfants nous même je pense
qu'on est on est vraiment des battants
donc ces deux sont des gens qui ont vécu
une manière incroyable mâcon à grand
mère me racontait le génocide arménien
hak elle a vécu vraiment avec des
histoires mais absolument rien dre
semblables je pense que vous pouvez être
que que dure d'un côté mais en même
temps avec une femme beaucoup de
tendresse beaucoup d'émotion quand par
rapport par rapport aux gens mais il ya
une grosse différence c'est que ces
gens-là c'est entre ce qu'ils montrent
ce qu'ils ont à l'intérieur alors vous
voulez d'abord devenir footballeur
professionnel
et puis le 10 mai 1970 date importante
dans la vie d'alain prost vous assister
au grand prix de monaco que vous
gagnerez 14 ans plus tard en 1984 une
étoile est née
199 grands prix cinquante et une
victoires quatre fois champion du monde
et en 93 l'année de votre quatrième
titre de champion du monde vous annoncez
votre départ définitif pourquoi avoir
pris cette décision à ce jour là dont 93
je me suis pas sentie très à l'aise
dans dans le milieu il n'y avait pas pas
dans le milieu mais il y avait
quelques
quelques relations un peu un peu
difficile je dirais dans le pendant la
saison n'est
qui m'ont fait penser qu'il me fallait
vraiment mieux finir sur un tir de
championnat alors que j'avais un contrat
encore pour l'année d'après avec woods
alors en 97 vous racheter l'écurie de
ligier fondé en 1976 en signant trois
ans de fourniture de moteurs avec
peugeot et vous avez déclaré à l'époque
nous visons le titre mondial dans trois
ans oui ça c'est vraiment un c'est pas
ma phrase je vous dis vraiment fait
honnêtement c'est en afrique parce que
tout le business plan qu'on avait fait
c'était minimum 5 ans minimum 5 ans pour
avoir une peau in une écurie de formule
1 compétitive on parlait même pas de
championne du monde d'où ça sort les
trois qui s'est passé c'est qu'on avait
un deal de cinq ans avec peugeot qui
était réduit à trois ans deux jours
avant l'annoncé parce que il ya eu des
tiraillements j'irai en interne de kid
qui avait rien à voir avec moi et il
fallait absolument présenter quelque
chose justement de présentable et la
seule chose de présentable si on a un
contrat de trois ans c'est bien de dire
qu'on va être champion du monde et donc
je me rappelle très très bien je suis
sortie de la grande armée avec hugues de
chaunac et je lui ai dit tu vois
je pense que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile que puisque dès le début vous
savez que ça va être très dur vous savez
c'est très difficile d'être avec un
grand constructeur donc soit c'est pour
ça je pense qu'il faut être économe en
somme constructeur à la limite il faut
que ce soit lui le moteur m'exprimer
ainsi alors que là j'ai été moi j'avais
mis le nom prost que je ne voulais pas
mettre d'ailleurs au départ parce que je
voulais plus un nom basé calquer un peu
sur la halle sur le nom france pour que
tout le monde a une sorte d'
appartenance à cette équipe alors j'ai
bel nom proche d'un côté et puis la
pression du constructeur et qui en fin
de compte sur de terre en termes de
communication fait ce qu'il veut alors
vous vous ai mis 22 millions d'euros
dans la sphère au départ vous avez perdu
mais c'est pas très grave c'est grave
mais henri thébault mieux quand il ya un
échec comme ça
partir en ayant perdu de l'argent je
tenais c'est pas plus mal parce qu'on
part les mains propres alors mais c'est
une idée à qui de vous demander de faire
sa guide rue qui était ministre des
sports à l'époque vous a poussé un peu
reprendre l'écurie ligier parce que on
connaît on va rentrer la norme que les
liens de françois mitterrand avec ligier
séguy truqués qui m'a approché parce
qu'il y avait déjà beaucoup de
discussions et moi j'étais chez mercedes
à l'époque j'étais vraiment très heureux
cc c'est venu à partir du grand prix de
france et puis bon c'est vu
les jeunes et ensemble à paris je suis
dit que j'étais pas intéressé donc ils
ont beaucoup insisté il n'y a qu'une
chose qui pourrait me faire changer
d'avis et que si un constructeur il
faudrait qu'ils soient français parce
que ça sert à rien de ne pas avoir au
moins une écurie française avec le coeur
de la voiture française donc le moteur
et avec un budget minimum 500 millions
sur cinq ans et on l'avait pas fait
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas justement
cette stabilité qu'il faut absolument
avoir un budget important alors le bilan
sportif de presse grand prix c83 grand
prix aucune victoire aucune pole
position un échec non l'échec c'est
d'arrêter échec c'est d'arrêter et
l'échec c'est d'avoir eu une image
terne une image souvent controversées ça
c'est un échec enfin le fait de dire on
n'a pas gagné on n'a pas fait de
ne pas marquer une victoire n'est pas
champion du monde ça c'est pas un échec
pour les raisons que leur expliquer tout
à l'heure c'est il ya une chose quand
même que je voudrais dire qu'on ne gagne
pas souvent on a commencé en 97 c'est
vrai qu'il y ait en formule 1 vous
saviez des cibles c'est comme dans la
vie et puis bon les constructeurs sont
arrivés tout de suite après deux trois
ans après en masse montfort d'art
achetées
stewart après toyota honda honda renault
qui a racheté benetton nous on est
restés un peu un peu tout seul ces gens
là à chaque fois qu'ils annoncent
quelque chose qu'est ce qu'ils annoncent
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont être
éventuellement champion du monde qu'il
en faut au minimum cinq ans de l'état
ils disent il faut dix ans numéro un
mondial ils ont dépensé 600 millions
d'euros avant de commencer de courir
ouais pourquoi nous on ne reproche mais
on peut pas accepter que qu'il faut du
temps sur l'équipe qui a très peu de
moyens et qu'on accepte tout à fait que
toyota rôle on dise il nous faudra cinq
ans pour gagner ouais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ça si je comprends mais je ne
vous avez peur de comprendre alors on va
parler un petit peu aussi de ce qui vous
a été reprochée parce qu'on a dit
finalement l'arrogance et l'orgueil qui
étaient des qualités pour s'imposer sur
un circuit c'était un handicap pour
manager d'entreprise arnoux a déclaré
n'est pas jean todt qui veut
pescarolo a déclaré un grand champion
n'est pas forcément un bon patron
allez-y vous a critiqué aussi de mon
alors le fait d'avoir fait des erreurs
dont l'arrogance sincèrement si je suis
arrogant de temps en temps c'est avec
certains journalistes ou certains
journalistes qui ont une méthode une
méthode que je ne peux pas accepter dans
sas a vraiment je reconnais l'arrogance
par exemple avec mon équipe certainement
pas trop de personnes peut dire
aujourd'hui dans mon équipe de taroudant
après quand vous parlez de trois anciens
pilotes il ya eu des déclarations
notamment de
autrement plus qualifier autrement plus
connu autrement plus célèbres notamment
des présidents de groupes autonomie qui
ont pas fait ce genre de déclarations
parce que quand on parle pas beaucoup de
la deûle à des problèmes économiques qui
les difficultés chercher de trouver des
sponsors à toutes les équipes mais si on
va chercher en france des gens comme toi
comme henri pescarolo monde comme
philippe arnould arnould sais bien qu'il
ya une volonté de fer man volonté de
nuire justement vous dites on n'aura
rien pardonné vous avez parlé de
lynchage total et vous portez une
accusations assez graves ou dit je
n'avais pas 100 millions de francs de
budget publicitaire a donné aux médias
et dès lors je n'y avait aucun pouvoir
sur que donc vous sous-entendez que
quand une une société peut donner des
budgets publicitaires à des journaux
même pour des voitures de tourisme
finalement on traite mieux leur écurie
vous savez très bien que c'est des
centaines et centaines de millions de
francs que ces gens-là dépense chaque
année entre les journaux et les ailes et
la télévision donc de toute façon vous
n'avez pas de vous n'aviez pas ce
pouvoir là en tous les cas on n'a pas de
pouvoir et on peut pas lutter contre ça
alors une donne importante ça a été
quand même l'échec du partenariat avec
peugeot
vous dites qu'ils ont pas assez dépensé
et à un moment vous avez d'ailleurs
pensé pour cela plus simple pour eux
finalement que l'écurie s'appelle
peugeot tout simplement et qui rentre au
capital
dès le début j'ai essayé d'inciter
beaucoup parce que je voyais très très
bien qu'il n'y avait pas une application
j'étais extrêmement déçus qu'ils aient
pris tout de suite après notre notre
accord le chemin du rallye dans la
mesure où bien entendu
bon ils ont une culture rallye donc ça
aurait été beaucoup plus facile de
gagner et puis bon dès qu'ils ont pris
la voir alice a été au détriment des
rats de la formule 1 et nous ce qu'on
recherchait c'est de cette stabilité
donc voyez très bien qu'on pouvait pas
en avoir et notre meilleure année face
qui aurait dû être notre meilleure année
c'était normalement la saison 2000 et on
a eu un échec incroyable on a cassé 57
moteur qui est pas un horaire du monde
donc on est
berne
on a pas mal comme ça mais bon c'est ça
nous a coûté vraiment très cher explique
dont 99 dont 99 on a on avait
signe un accord pour se séparer et en
avance ce que je voyais très bien que
cette saison 2000 à être une une
catastrophe et on avait fait un accord
pour aller acheter justement notre
client chez renault alors justement
problème avec peugeot renault préfère
lancer sa propre écurie et ironie du
sort le lancement du retour de renault
en formule 1 était annoncée pratiquement
le même jour
que votre retrait donc c'était un petit
peu petit peu dur j'imagine pour vous
aurez c'est dur mais bon ce qui était
dur c'était là de deux ans avant de ne
pas avoir pu moi j'aurais beaucoup aimé
concrétiser cet accord avec renault
devrait proposer toutes sortes de
partenariats possibles même le rachat
bien entendu total de l'équipe je reste
complètement persuadés ça c'est quand
même important parce que si j'ai fait
aussi dans ce pays ce projet c'est pas
simplement pour avoir un jour une équipe
de f1 c'est parce que je pensais qu'on
pourrait gagner avec un constructeur
mais je reste persuadé qu'en france on a
une on a des gens absolument incroyable
seule chose qu'il faut c'est du temps
d'instabilité parce qu'ils ont ils ont
énormément des relents je reste persuadé
que renault aurait à mon avis mieux fait
dans le futur de reprendre cette équipe
et de l'argent tendu de la lgv est
blonde et la développer évidemment vous
n'êtes pas eu de stabilité parce que
d'abord le président de peugeot a changé
un donc ce n'était pas son histoire à
lui c'était l'histoire de son
prédécesseur nouvelle majorité à
l'assemblée nationale aussi c'est vrai
que guide rue le type que vous avez
amené la demande a été plus là et puis
les 35 heures c'est vrai que les écuries
anglo saxon elles ont le double de gens
pour la même masse salariale tout ça ça
fait partie d'un ensemble c'est vrai
c'est à dire que quand on fait ce projet
on dit bon on sait qu'on prend un risque
de le faire en france et quand même eu
trois ou quatre équipes qui ont quand
même dû arrêter
qui ont été liquidés dans les équipes de
formule 1 dans l'es10 quinzaine d'années
donc on sait que c'est pas facile à
partir du moment où il ya une synergie
où il ya quand même une volonté
politique il ya un constructeur
automobile moi je me suis dit là c'est
le moment de le faire je pense qu'on va
apprécier le rouleau compresseur
malheureusement c'est vrai que la
dissolution de l'assemblée nous a fait
mal dans la mesure où il ya eu en même
temps un déménagement de magny cours et
quand même un fief socialiste donc j'ai
eu tous les problèmes possibles le
comité décentralisation du management
vous était aussi victime des grands
constructeurs qui veulent éliminer ce
qu'on appelle les garagistes quoi
maintenant cellectis indépendants comme
ça ça fait plutôt partie du paysage
victime du crack de la nouvelle économie
puisque yahoo était prêt à mettre 100
millions de dollars dans votre affaire
bon qui doit seul coup la nouvelle
économie s'est un peu écroulé victime du
11-septembre
puisque la famille saoudienne al walid
était prête aussi à vous aider enfin
voilà quoi c'est vrai que vous avez joué
un petit peu de malchance que ça va plus
on a eu énormément de mal chance mais
met vraiment en m dans cette situation
je reste toujours sur ma doctrine qui
dit que la malchance on la tire ouais et
il fallait qu'on trouve des solutions
peut-être avant et je reste convaincu
que c'est à la base comprennent qu'on
crée vraiment sa chance ou pas alors
vous dites ce que j'ai essayé de faire
on ne le reverra plus il faut pas rêver
c'est à dire que vous pensiez qui aura
pas d'écurie au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
un championnat constructeurs ouais donc
il ya une vraie un vrai problème
économique important les sponsors il y
aura certainement une ou deux autres
équipes qui vont être dans l'embarras
dans très peu de temps et c'est un
championnat constructeurs donc qu'il y
aura peut-être plus de 12 équipes n'aura
peut-être plus que 7 8 9 ouais et des
petites équipes comme ça c'est
impossible dans la mesure où les
sponsors vont aller quand même plutôt là
les constructeurs faut quand même savoir
qu'une équipe ça c'est des chiffres mais
c'est important une équipe 4e au
championnat c'est comme saubert qui est
quand même une équipe qui ressemble un
peu enfin qui ressemble un peu la nôtre
n'at il n'a eu que 4,3 pour cent de
visibilité télévision de l'année
dernière et 70 80 % sont répartis dans
les trois premiers au championnat donc
c'est très difficile d'aller les séduire
les sponsors sans visibilité les
demandes de 200 250 millions sponsor
numéro un ce n'est même plus des mots
non parce que 300 millions pourrait
poser des stickers sur la voiture il
faut être un très bon vendeur donc pas
facile au final j'avais le sentiment que
vous êtes fait avoir dans toute cette
affaire
j'ai le sentiment de d'habitude c'est
toujours je regrette jamais rien donc là
je commence a dit de me dire quand même
je regrette un peu ce qui s'est passé de
notre côté j'aurai certainement
regretter de ne pas l'avoir fait je
trouve que il ya quand même une en a la
pression moi j'ai l'impression que ça
arrange beaucoup de gens qui est plus d'
équipes de f1 en france donc il fallait
en fin de compte quel était le l'homme
providentiel le plus apte 1 a en fin de
compte a montré l'échec c'était moi et
ça arrange on sait que la victime
expiatoire si c'était à refaire vous
feriez quoi pas pareil mais gégé guide
russe est le premier conclu
jean 22 millions d'euros plongez avec
vous je ferais exactement ce que j'ai
dit au directeur général de peugeot deux
jours avant la signature elle ne fait
pas je ne fais plus parce que je lui ai
dit malheureusement je suis revenu sont
un parole parce que je ne sais pas
possible cette sept mois de travail et
comme quoi il faut jamais quand on a une
impression la haine mène avec beaucoup
de pression derrière il faut pas y aller
il faut pas forcer le destin à forcer le
destin mais maintenant je vais faire
quoi
maintenant je vais partir en vacances
réfléchir à réfléchir à comment rebondir
d'une heure où d'une autre parce que
toute façon c'est évident donc je
voulais revenir en formule 1 quand même
c'est pas impossible pas impossible mais
bon mais il ya dix ans déjà j'ai déjà eu
deux contacts mais c'est pas ça sert à
rien aujourd'hui je peux absolument pas
me remettre dans un truc sans avoir pris
un peu de repos merci alain prost et
vous exprimer aussi franchement merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
merci
hélas
ça
sans effort voici elisa tovati
[Musique]
c'est chaud c'est chaud ce soir vous
connaissez laurent baffie
alors ma fille elisa tovati qu'on a
découverte dans la vérité si je mens 2
dans le rôle de chochana boutboul
dont josé garcia tombe éperdument
amoureux vous appelez elisa à cause de
la chanson qu'on vient d'entendre tovati
parce que c'est moins commun touati
exact voilà mes tubes on nous appelle
zazou oui c'est vrai c'est sa coiffe les
zazous ya pas de problème à voilà alors
au niveau du cinéma on vous verra
bientôt dans sexe très opposées d'eric
assous et en attendant vous sortez un
single mais j'ai toujours été passionné
pour l'ach par la chanson et le cinéma
je voulais faire les deux depuis
toujours et ça a mis un peu plus de
temps pour la chanson donc le single
sort mal en pis l'album un peu plus tard
voilà il va sortir car cet album au
printemps ça y est il est prêt à en
écouter le single
pour toi
m
c'est ce qu'on va faire on va vous
regarder c'est encore mieux mazères
ça va
voilà elisa tovati moi je t'aime pour
rien une chanson écrite par richard
cette fin
jean richard seff c'est pas n'importe
qui certains droits aux producteurs de
toulouse qui a travaillé avec le normand
axelle red madère cabrel voilà elisa
tovati moi je tempo rien à voir vous
n'êtes pas fait pas vite fait vingt
quand vous faites
un peu de temps c'est le début de
l'année alors dont bientôt l'album bruel
va écrire pour vous oui rick allison
axelle renoir didier gaulle manas daniel
seff c'est une très belle équipe
d'auteurs compositeurs autour de moi
j'en suis très fier voilà j'espère que
maintenant le public va écouter va bien
sûr et quand ont-ils dit elle est ravie
elle est aux anges et bernard ça va il
est content aussi oui ses parents
tu sois content j'ai envie que ma
famille soit aussi exactement bonsoir
maman voilà
alors bien la fameuse est venu ici
c'était donc pour la vérité si je mens 2
en tant que shauna boutboul et vous
aviez un fiancé à montréal et vous nous
avez dit ou lui se passe très bien
d'avoir influence à montréal il suffit
de prendre l'avion puis voilà d'avoir
l'argent pour payer le téléphone
évidemment c'est un peu plus cher quand
il est à montréal la distance n'a jamais
été un problème quand on est amoureux
et aujourd'hui est-ce que je suis obligé
de répondre je sais la vérité est obligé
de le dire tout ça vous est de nouveau
célibataire
et oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous
l'avez lui à montréal vous apparaît non
ça me toujours très fort ah bon ça c'est
encore pire alors oui en quelque sort
plus triste sort d'une certaine façon
non même si ces fameux syndrome véronika
loubry à connaissez pas bien belle si
elle avait son jules latérite aoki et
c'est la distance c'est la distance 20
des yeux c'est très difficile et c'est
vrai que la distance n'arrange pas les
choses mais il ya eu d'autres choses
qu'ils en font il a attrapé ailleurs
c'est un foutu un peu la mer
il faut dire les choses et 10 à vous
avez quand même un coeur d'artichaut
j'avoue je viens d'en mais ça me fait
plaisir parce que vous avouer ça c'est
bien voilà vous laisser séduire non non
je me laisse pas séduire facilement au
contraire mais quand je suis séduite
j'ai envie de tout donner tout à
l'hôpital il y a
donc maintenant vous êtes une vraie
femme
maintenant je sais pourquoi je dis ça
alors on a déjà perdu 7 kg 1 télé joue
un peu creusé comme ça tout va très bien
je vous le dis
je sais pas si je vous aime bien donc
elisa on va voir si vous êtes en phase
avec le public parce que quand on veut
être une star c'est important de bien
sentir son public on va faire une
interview opinion publique
là non
oui
merci philippe
le physique d'un homme ne séduit les
françaises qu'à 4% mais pour 53 % des
françaises c'est la personnalité de
l'homme qui les séduit le plus et vous
moi aussi c'est la personnalité à vous
c'est physique ah ouais s'il est la
mieux tant mieux mais sinon c'est pas le
plus important est votre ami de montréal
il était
il a fait il n'y a plus rien maintenant
38 % des femmes préfèrent le matin au
réveil et 73% des femmes françaises
préfèrent le soir au coucher moi je
préfère à n'importe quand n'importe
quand même en pleine émission tue pas
justement je voulais tant par les
belles tournées ont été visés ça va être
très bien cette émission bon alors
justement pour 34% des français sait où
il veut quand il veut moi c'est pas
quand il veut c'est quand je veux pas
d'accord
[Musique]
les affiches 69,1 tu vas le succès non
non c'est pas ça
c'est vous qui me posais une question je
vous écoute
l'interview que vous avez fait avec un
pro ça m'a donné une petite idée il ya
une phrase du dalaï lama que j'aime
beaucoup qui dit oublier l'échec mais
n'oublie pas la leçon moi la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
quelle a été votre principal échec dans
votre vie et quelle leçon vous en avez
tiré à malabo
jamais jamais eu tellement d'échec
disons que je me suis fait virer de la
télé par exemple en 92-93 avec mon ami
laurent baffie ma faute à
la banque c'est un échec parce qu'après
j'ai passé trois en dehors et la leçon
que j'en ai tiré c'est qu'il fallait pas
se prendre au sérieux pas avoir la
grosse tête pas se prendre pour une star
et que les gens qui viennent ici le
samedi soir ils viennent pas pour moi
parce que si la semaine prochaine à
quelqu'un d'autre
ils viendront pour lui voilà c'est là le
sens commercial
56% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
dans le noir et vous moi aussi j'aime
bien noir soit quelque chose comme ça
très mystérieux cette comptine imaginer
des choses
alors 33% des femmes disent toujours ou
souvent à leurs partenaires ce qu'elle
souhaite qu'il lui fasse et vous moi je
sais pas trop alors mettez c'était moins
bien qu'on me fasse
bloc le virus je les laisse improviser à
dacca déchets n'improvise pas bien les
jeter quand même il a une deuxième
chance à une deuxième chance très bon
tirage
et vise à 49% des femmes refusent de se
faire attacher et vous j'ai jamais
essayé mais ça doit être sympa je vais
essayer
il ya attaché attaché je sais pas si on
prend un foulard de satin et qu'on
attache un bras au lit ça peut être un
peu sensuelle mais les gens à ligoter
ses débuts car je sais le début la
ligoté bâillonné demande de rançon
ah ouais d'accord
66% des femmes sont choqués par les
pratiques sadomasochistes et vous je
suis pas choqué mais ça m'intéresse pas
en tout cas pas du tout non chacun fait
ce qu'il veut
privé c'est l'intimité je vous tends
choquer mais ça me tente pas moi je suis
plutôt quelqu'un qui aime la tendresse
et la sensuelle normal
alors
j'aime pas trop qu'on me fasse mal mais
vous aimeriez faire mal non non je ne
supporte pas faire mal à quelqu'un
d'avoir mal non plus fouetter calme-toi
39% des femmes c'est beaucoup refusent
la fellation et vous n'ont juste pas
magnéto auxerre
alors oui 65 ans et plus avec 39 pour la
fondation de ses 65 % des femmes
refusent des relations à trois
mois je refuse pas j'ai jamais essayé
gens j'en ressens pas le besoin je suis
très bien à deux quand j'étais à 2
71 % des gens seraient choqués qu'un
couple d'amis proches leur propose
d'aller dans un club échangiste et vous
je pense que je serai curieuse mais que
j'irais pas comme jc jamais allé non
je promets je suis jamais allé jamais
les où je suis curieuse de savoir
comment ça se passe et d'invention j'ai
pas très envie d'y aller donc c'est très
bien parce qu'il va l'emporter si la
curiosité
après l'amour
36% des français se lavent
29% dorment
8% fume 7% boivent ou manche
6% recommencez pas beaucoup quand même
6% 5% regarde la télé et vous
moi j'aime bien
rêver regarder la personne avec qui je
veux faire l'amour on va rester là
dessus c'est beau
à
elisa tovati m messieurs 3
[Musique]
et maintenant quoi
key
ma gueule
ouais si joey starr
joey starr bonsoir vous êtes ici pour la
sortie d'un single qui s'appelle gazelle
et qui figure sur la bande son du film
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre
d'alain chabat vous savez comment fait
que les petites mains joey pour faire
croire à pour faire quoi montre lui pas
fait alors qu'en expliqué joe et en même
temps tu as une bague énorme toiture
pour un gros pain d'un tag hull qu'est
ce que tu veux mon grand
[Musique]
pour mieux se salue
comme le
film
[Musique]
sur les camps savoie seuls intérêts
à joey starr gaz est
extrait de la bande originale du fils
d'alain chabat astérix et obélix mission
cléopâtre alors alain chabat est un vrai
fan de vous en l'an 2000 avait fait un
documentaire qui s'appelait authentique
réalisé par lui et sa rb6 stefan bellof
d'ailleurs vous deviez jouer dans le
film astérix et vous deviez jouer le
rôle de nick la police mais vous a fait
vous êtes disparu du scénario à la
quatrième version pourquoi vous étiez en
taule au moment du tournage n'ont même
pas non même pas non alors il y a un an
sortait une compilation des remixes de
ntm c'était un vrai carton ça c'est
énormément vendu est aujourd'hui ntm est
un peu en stand by no way
et emme est une grosse machine et qu'à
chaque fois qu'on part pour faire une
tournée vous faire un six mois de promo
à répéter trois mois avant pendant tout
un truc à chaque coup d'entre elles et
avec les aime ça promet toujours si ça
lui mois de préparation ou autre et ça
nous permettait pas de faire ce qu'on
avait envie de faire à côté quoi ces 10
cas là on va essayer quand même alors
vous avez quand même vendu 2 millions de
disques avec ntm et ça fait quatre ans
car rien de frais qui est sorti est ce
que est ce que c'est pour toujours ou
vous pensez re bosser avec kool shen ntm
on met toujours quoi 80 faire l'album
dans les traits de dakhla alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes façon en fait même
si ça prend son sens garde connaît
aujourd'hui vous vivez à saint-ouen dans
une communauté hip hop dans un pavillon
il ya tout votre bande qu'émilie la pop
hip hop non
nous on n'est pas des beatniks ans
on vient aux collectivités mairies
communautés alors vous dites certaines
nuits on se retrouve à 50 alors cessé
d'envoyer votre studio 1
l'enregistrement et puis aussi vous
faites votre émission pour skyrock voilà
le jeudi ça s'appelle jeudi jour de ces
demies et le samedi s'appellent
métaphore malabry
ça vous emmerde d'être devenu un des uns
des personnages comme ça des français
vit dans un monde à chartres à 5 donc ça
m'intéresse traite ou quoi ouais mais
bon je me suis dit quoi ouais vous êtes
médiatique maintenant ouais je crois
marino
[Musique]
alors attention le le voyait il est dans
la place alors la coulée durée on est en
82 ans durant ce début d'année tisser
des années lycée bon là je suis à la
place votre professeur et vous me
confier tout à l'heure alors qu'on se
lâche elle a confié péter les tabous
tous les trois ans arrivant au
superlatif que vous étiez plutôt du
genre fond de la classe
alors ça se passe et comment quel genre
de la visite et les deux zozos la tête
des gens ferment pas dans le lobe quoi
tu parle raconte dans mon droit de
parler quoi
tranquille quoi déjà la révolte la
banlieue quoi
[Musique]
attention on est dans le berceau des
beaux-arts on est dans le 9 3 ces votes
et si les potes la petite délinquance et
en arrivant voulu confier parce que
commence à devenir super proches ici
c'est le kiff self et grades
hadjaoui 97 côté sombre c'est l'incident
la boulette conneries celle qui donnera
quelques mois de prison bon obligeant
paraissait la sphère de l'hôtesse de
l'air turque et ce qui s'est passé ouah
conneries tu crois que tu as long tail
tranquille quoi on échange de 3,4 normal
quoi la [__] mais une claque à dilma -
une claque toi
ouais c'est pourquoi il faut que
j'explique quoi manger il faut at war
mais moi une claque quoi t'as pas de
qunu quoi quoi
voilà alors moi je réplique quoi j'étais
sa tête fois tranquille quoi tu ferais
pas au légitime dépense quoi
ya pas hésité à consultation avec ma
bête alors cette note gauche croit elle
existe vraiment ouais quoi tu veux qui
fait bien on va faire un repas froid à
temporaire
alors merci d'un tm que les jo et
c'était vraiment sympa
la semaine prochaine je recevrai
[Musique]
les stars au lignage
pensez quoi de la caricature qui font de
vous le guignol qu'est ce que j'en pense
marquant c'est drôle c'est drôle invite
à côté moi dans 93 le sport national
c'est quand même la chambre est donc
ouais donc je n'ai pas de problème à ce
qu'on rigole deux mois qu'on attend que
c'est bien fait quoi voilà bien joey
starr tout le monde vous connaît mais on
vous connaît peu on va parler de vous et
de votre vie
alors votre vrai nom c'est didier
morville vous êtes ne donnait pas
l'adresse quand même nom
didier morville ouais c'est ça vous êtes
né dans une cité la seine-saint-denis
voltige derrière près votre père assis
l'irascible comme comme non hein mais
confondre ouais vous ai fait une chanson
d'ailleurs s'appelle laisse pas traîner
ton fils ouais pour lui parler ou enfin
j'écris une chanson parce que j'avais je
fais ce que j'ai donc après après comme
je disais l'enfant mots pour lui parler
c'est un peu tard maintenant ouais votre
mère aussi vous l'avez retrouvé assez
tardivement ouais mais si on regarde et
vous être regardée comme ses joueurs
et les repas de famille quand on vous
disait qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand
tu seras grand bray pontier quoi je
répondrai pas
j'avais pas vraiment d'idée donc
alors 82 vous avez un choc vous avez 20
ans vous allez au trocadéro et vous
découvrez deux jeunes américains qui
danse le smurf au son d'un ghetto
blaster c'est les débuts du hip hop vous
rencontrez kool shen à ce moment là une
chaîne en fait ils habitaient le côté de
lamu moi j'étais d'un côté ni de l'autre
donc c'était déjà faire aucun essai
avant moi j'étais comme tous les
banlieusards à l'époque remontaient sur
paris des et on
pourra le voir ce que font les autres
ouais mais quand vous dansiez tous les
deux dans le métro vous gagner du pognon
ouais un petit peu résidait au nombre
des miettes
sensible d'une heure et demie et ça
marche c'est bien gagner de la tune dans
tous les deux dans le métro châtelet les
halles
gens qui font la manche ça marche bien
ça ça ils subviennent quoi ouais vous
gagnez plus que votre père par exemple
non je faisais autre chose pour gagner
plus que mon père alors en 84 donc c'est
la fin de l'émission de sydney est en
fait le graphique ci remplace un peu le
smurf et la breakdance dans le mouvement
hip hop c'est ça ouais le graffiti c'est
un truc en fait
enfin l'ami de cushing à 20 livres
d'histoire géographie qu'une toute
petite photo comme ça dans mes troupes à
new york est un
party down en quoi ouais ouais on a
commencé un pisser dans les coins et
puis après ça les gens alors au départ
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est ken tm
c'était un groupe de tagguer en 86 avant
d'être un groupe de
chanteurs et puis un jour vous
rencontrez 10 3 éme année johnny go et
ils vous disent le taxer de la merde
c'est le rap qui au top vous fait re
mais enfin ils essaient de les expliquer
qu on fait de la merde écornée des
merdes c'est plus comme ça ouais et nous
nous les prenons pas pour pas grand
monde non pas grand chose aussi à
l'époque dense éditions valor répondre
et on a été créé mon premier texte dans
la cuisine de mon père de leur montrer
que l'on peut le faire nous aussi les
gros êtes vous dit à ce moment-là nous
dans le rap on va tout déchirer et ça a
donné ça
[Musique]
pour travailler la charité ni
il est
ok le boulot
merci
il m'avait
l'état quand on les a même en état
d'ébriété avancé souffre mentalement
attardés
critique mais prototype du pot
c'est le mois
ce qu'en pensent les héros
[Musique]
m
je ne peux pas le plus endetté que j'ai
dû
oublier
[Musique]
intitulé
le s'il est tombé
celle ci y avoir aussi si je profite là
- commandes dans la ville de paris
boston
[Musique]
non
je suis
[Musique]
non
sur la corde à linge par 6 2
la demande sur l'attentât non je pense
de moi
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend mais qu'est
ce qu'on attend pour ne plus suivre les
règles si je mettais
[Musique]
voilà
alors est ce que c'est vrai
que votre maison de disques epic vous a
suggéré à un moment que ntm qui veut
dire nique ta mère ça signifie le nord
transmet le message non jamais jamais
moi je peux je peux prétendre un truc
c'est que je peux parti je crois des
rares groupes thé du seul groupe en
france qu'à jamais présenté une maquette
avant de faire un album quoi way to play
noté m
ça vous plaît bien franchement
après tout seul parce qu'elle est quoi
mais tout ça n'est pas mariée c'est ça
c'est un bon parti moi aussi
pensez quoi du rap français en général
jesta bayard ap rap c'est comme tout il
ya vous mourrez humour ouais
c'est pas important
parce qu'il a un côté caustique nous on
est des hooligans derrière qui fait bien
de prendre des pincettes parce que je
peux tu éclaté alors et ça c'est
démesuré ton propos parce que ça parle
et agit
tout de suite la violence la violence
menace et un tuba voilà ça c'est
l'exemple
je trouve un peu trop virulent pour la
télé
alors je dis c'était quoi était son papa
la question cédera de français c'est que
je les dis akhenaton il peut les toucher
doc gynéco c'est du plastique sans
consistance est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
dire finalement on fait un peu du
gangsta rap et que les autres font du
rap normal moi je suis pas gros ce temps
là mais gangsta rap ça veut dire qu'on a
un gangster obligatoires ben un peu un
peu s'il ya marqué gangsters à vent
râpent d'accord
oui
la garda car je crois que moi je suis
plus dans un passé on doit constituer je
crois que je suis plus dans une
catégorie ce constat d'une certaine
urgence en fait qu'on raconte développe
kouame mais en aucun cas je cherche à me
faire passer pour un bandit où je pense
que déjà déjà s'est moqué de respect aux
gens qui font ça et qui sont son coup
d'essai comme on dit nécessité fait loi
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui font ça
et ne feront pas le choix compagne
d'autre choix que pas d'autres outils
non pour pouvoir s'en sortir
bon déjà depuis ces gens là moi je les
ai vus vivre je sais ce que c'est ainsi
donc par rapport à ça j'ai aucun droit
de me réclamer gangster voit nulle ou
autres quoi je fais de la musique donc
j'ai cette chance là quoi il est pas
très très chaud sur la france vous avez
déclaré le fn est dissous mais les
racistes reste assez moi qui disent ah
ouais je sais pas si je parle comme ça
mais allons-y je sais pas on est
toujours me direz vous on est toujours
dans le même pays de collabos ou 1,61
drabo qu'une fois les américains
arrivent et met d'ailleurs en ce moment
là qu'a regarder la tv qu on s est
plaint de jeu je t'ai lumine jeudi en
coin flux sont atteintes à sa suite donc
qui s'appelait quoi donc ça veut dire
qu'on est bien aux apps il colle à bout
quoi qui moi je suis pas très problème
c'est que moi je viens dès fin mai par
an vient des colonies moi je suis né ici
quoi mais et puis on n'a pas oublié
qu'on est venu chercher et puis que la
france est un pays cosmopolite donc
donner
moi j'ai 34 ans je paie beaucoup
d'impôts en fait encore sentir que je
suis pas forcément à ma place il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui va pas quoi
déjà c'est le fait que j'ai une tête
ramé ça joue quoi est presque quoi tient
le sourire aussi le vent oui mais ça
c'est le sourire shine quand je les vois
je suis pas donc il est vrai jamais
est-ce que j'ai l'impression joey starr
que malgré votre succès vous avez du mal
à vous sortir de la banlieue votre
enfance vous dit le sac à dos de la
banlieue il reste accroché à toi mon
univers et de la coi je pense que si on
sort de ça je sais pas si j'ai encore
des outils pouvant eux
moi je pense que je suis là parce qu'il
ya une raison d'être je veux dire pas
j'ai un média dans les mains donc j'en
profite pour présenter comme je le peux
la main la majorité silencieuse donc
c'est surtout ça en fait on ne combat
quoi
ouais j'habite encore là à côté parce
que notre ailleurs pour le moment quoi
bien j'ai besoin des miens surtout quoi
c'est à dire c'est mon essence quoi et
puis des fois joey starr vous pétez un
peu les plans soirée
j'ai rêvé
alors on va pas faire le listing de tous
vos ennuis avec la justice mais
c'est vrai que vous avez eu souvent
l'occasion de vous affronter à vos
comptes en droit non je vous affrontez
une fois non ouais mais fait peur
j'arrive devant chez j'arrive devant
chez sony et puis je sais puisque avait
une entrevue que le journal que je
dirigeais à l'époque à bout ça faisait
plus qu'il y avait moi je sais ce qu'il
dirait moi j'étais avec avec mon amie
béatrice et puis des gens nous ont sauté
dessus et puis dans l'entrevue j'ai vu
ça un monde était drogué un truc à notre
super anodin voire carrément il y avait
une page complète sinon page complète
avec deux lignes devraient c'est à dire
qu'on était dans la rue béatrice et moi
je suis ce qui était vrai le reste est
un lieu donc de 50 revue c'était des
interviews donc c'est l'interview du mec
qui nous vient vers le nul acquis ouais
mais je pense que je pense que quand
même
c'était le mec là qui vous aviez ouvert
le crâne qui disait six mois il m'a
ouvert le crâne ouais mais je pense que
je pense que ça devient curieux des
choses il ya des crânes intéressant à
voir derrière
vous raconter d'histoires on n'en met
maintenant tout je pense que je pense
que même si l'entrevue c'est un journal
de merde il faut savoir une chose c'est
que quand même fait du pseudo
journalisme donc fait ces jeunes est
vendu il ya sept ans dans ceux de
journalisme non mais c'est pas pour donc
ceux de journalisme il ya journalisme ce
qui veut dire qu'au moins un minimum on
se rencontre
et quand on se regarde c'est juste je
sais pas savoir ce qui assure un pv
comme cette journaliste pouvait le
savoir je pense et son pv a quand même
marqué qu'à trois personnes qui
faisaient dessus je suis tout seul avec
ma copine
maintenant si c'est moi après qui passe
pour l'agresseur c'est quand même assez
bizarre donc le fait que vous ayez écrit
ça et je vous connaissais pas en plus ça
je le trouve déranger je vais demander
pendant je pas pendant un quart d'heure
en le suivant dans la rue s'il
connaissait ma ganache
pour savoir de quoi il parlait si vous
connaissez en fait voilà et c'est ce qui
lui a fait peur ce jour là si je m'étais
écouter j'aurais joué au football avec
lui je n'ai pas fait ce que je ne fais
pas
ce qu'il faut dire la vérité c'est qu'un
mec est passé en bagnole qui a vu que
j'allais me faire assassiner sur place
qui m'a recueillie dans sa voiture jamie
deux gros coups de pied dans la bagnole
des portières étaient en creux comme ça
le mec s'est arrêté huit cents mètres
plus loin j'ai dit je suis sorti de la
voiture vous voulez que je vous
rembourse pour la porter un maillot non
c'est pas grave l'assurance paiera si
vous aviez mis dans ma tête j'ai aimé
dans la bagnole je serais mort oui et en
plus avec un policier l'a qui voulaient
même pas vous en avez là un policier
il a sauté sera
bien
pour finaliser sa souvenu donc c'est que
voilà c'est fini maintenant tchad
jusqu'à vendre
et l'hôtesse de l'air c'est elle qui
vous avez agressé aussi bah ouais mais
bon comme je dis toujours c'est sans
obligation d'achat on en fait ce qu'on
n'en veut plus ça change rien faut juste
savoir qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui quand
même il à air france qui nous demande
car qui me demande de l'argent par
rapport à un manque à gagner vu qu'elle
a quand même pour une gifle après six
mois de congé maladie donc j'ai dû à un
manque à gagner c'est pendant un an et
demi
de care france qui me demande ça l'arc
est rétabli la sécurité sociale qui me
demandent aussi d'argent ouais ça veut
dire que j'ai déjà samoa déjà coûté 200
mille balles entre 200 et 300 mille
balles et là on leur demande encore 300
et il avait giflé en première pour soi
comme en france prix là maintenant
justement un an mais je leur ai dit
raillé pour ce prix là au sprint j'avais
des femmes c'est pas bien et vous aider
à mieux là de quoi mais mme gillard
mieux plus calme c'est parce que vous
avez un disque à vendre parce que vous
êtes fait soigner
pour diego
non là c'est une branche est là c'est
parce pas bon sur cette île ironie fogel
c'est peut-être lui qui va toi tu as
beaucoup
comme des amoureux peut-être un méta
maurer one façon je suis amoureux
chamorro ce que je fais je suis mort
d'autres choses enfin attaque mais au
sein même pas s'avancer non c'est pas ça
c'est que je pense que je pense qu'avant
avant j'allais sur les plantes et les
gta v kool shen donc il y avait un côté
amy yang et plus aujourd'hui je me
retrouve tout seul donc par c'est à moi
de le jeu de l'agencé ce côté les lions
n'ont pas plus mal parce qu'on entend
parler plus et puis ah ouais c'est vrai
pas une brute épaisse qu'un petit shorty
bonnes affaires les dents en or et c'est
bien
avec ce retrait du temps avant que
alors joey starr s'établir à travailler
la chauffer les pneus la vie elle-même
déraillé joey starr vous êtes un petit
peu souvent dans la quatrième dimension
on va vous faire une interview quatrième
dimension
[Applaudissements]
non
serge khalfon qui dit que vous avez
bougé par le jingle milos pas vous le
dire
il a raison en selle alors quel pays de
la quatrième dimension
choisiriez vous pour vivre le pays où on
travaille pas le pays on vieillit pas où
le pays on n'est jamais malades
sauver ou je m'appelle bazooka et on
rigole tout le temps la ville que vous
choisiriez dans la quatrième dimension
la ville où il n'y a que vous celle où
vous n'avez que des amis ou si elle n'y
a que des femmes
car c'est toujours ça en fait il n'y a
que mes amis dans la quatrième dimension
tout est possible vous en profitez pour
aller sur mars pour se taper log crous
ou pour faire avorter la maman d'hitler
piétiner la mer de l'air pendant qu'elle
est enceinte
je suis myope comme ça je m'appelle
nique ta mère pour ces raisons-là d
après vous prendre le truc avant l'offre
c'est pas terrible que jeune d'errance
dans la quatrième dimension le temps est
différent vous en profitez pour vous
offrir un retour dans votre enfance une
fois par semaine pour faire des
escapades dans le futur ou pour vivre le
temps présent au maximum en l'étirant
ivoire suite
quatrième dimension il ya un autre
calendrier
vous choisissez le mois où l'argent est
gratuit le mois où les joints tourner
pendant 30 jours ou le mois où on bande
quatre semaines qu'est-ce qui fait déjà
tiré ouais il a doublé et filmé toute la
journée jeux ouais je je suis comme tout
le monde
va pas dans le monde du quartier quoi je
suis quartier c'est la cachant
non mais je vais vous laisser partir mon
petit lobby bancaire
et j'accueille maintenant madame de
l'avant des roms
ce soir je ne vous appellerai pas marie
laforêt perd 6,7 en promotion pour quoi
que ce soit vous êtes ici pour vous
exprimer merci d'avoir choisi d'ailleurs
tout le monde en parle je voulais dire à
ce sujet thierry tout à l'heure vous
avez dit
si c'était pas moi ce serait un autre ce
serait pareil je vous dis tout de suite
il savait pas été vous je serais pas là
merci c'est gentil
je vous demande de vous inviter
bien alors il ya quinze jours sur ce
plateau antoine schuller le fils de
didier schuller
en compagnie du journaliste jean paul
guillaume est venu témoigner et
d'ailleurs depuis sa servi à quelque
chose parce que depuis didier schuller
est rentré en france et il a été
incarcéré suite à la dénonciation de son
fils de l'actualité d'un vrai [__] la
dre alors effectivement alors la presse
a dit en parlant de la dénonciation
d'antoine qu'ils étaient manipulés
manipulé par jeu spa par les socialistes
pour faire du tort à chirac on a dit
aussi qu'il était manipulé par vous
alors si c'est jospin qu'il manipule on
comprend effectivement et si c'est vous
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi
vous l'auriez
manipuler antoine schouller
malheureusement d'ailleurs et personne
ne peut le manipuler vous avez expliqué
interview vérité
on
alors la reprendre les choses au début
pour tout le monde comprenne bien vous
avez été mariée avec un ami de didier
schuller qui s'appelle eric de l'avant
des rats qui est un français agent de
change qui vit en suisse lui il avait
été mariée en premières noces avec
catherine hennessy qu'héritière adecco
n'y a qu'ainsi ils ont eu un enfant des
pantins s'appelle diego de l'avant des
rats qui est ami avec antoine schuller
fac était ami avec antoine schuller
comme les deux papas étaient amis alors
on va d'abord commencer par ça parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé dans la presse et
j'aimerais que vous expliquer là dessus
votre mariage avec eric de l'avant des
races s'est pas bien passé très bien
passé il s'est extrêmement bien passé
j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur un homme
courtois intelligent cultivé
gentil et pendant je dois dire pendant
13 ans j'ai vécu un mariage extrêmement
heureux jusqu'aux derniers mois de notre
notre mariage qui a été très
traumatisants extrêmement bouleversant
et où je n'ai strictement rien compris
et ce qui se passait voilà vous pouvez
continuer non je continue parce que
c'est vrai que ce n'était pas très bien
passé avec catherine si ça c'était ça
c'est et comme pour moi ça s'est
extrêmement bien passé pour elle a eu
deux enfants donc avec monsieur de
l'avant des rats elle a été je crois
extrêmement heureuse pendant pendant
sept ans et brusquement les choses ont
dérapé pour elle elle a eu un accident
sur lequel elle avait des gros doutes
c'est un accident de moto pour elle ce
sera un accident de voiture pour moi à
partir de ce moment là ses amis
commencent à changer à son égard son
mari l'a dit alcoolique drogué
dépressive dans une secte et dieu sait
quoi et il va tenter de la mettre par la
fenêtre
ce qui fait que catherine m6 partira
avec son sac à main laissant ses deux
enfants derrière elle je suis persuadé
moi même puisque je n'ai aucune raison
de douter de ce que nous dit mon mari
que effectivement catherine m6 est une
folle furieuse donc je vais élever diego
il
l comme mes propres enfants et je les
élève donc en même temps que mes propres
enfants dans une ambiance extrêmement
joyeuse et agréable votre pari a eu un
comportement effectivement un petit peu
bizarre avec vous il dormait avec un
couteau à cran d'arrêt soit table de
nuit c'est vrai nom mais pas il me
montrait le côtoie de fin d'année c'est
vrai qu'il vous prenait le pouls pendant
la nuit pour savoir s'il s'était
présenté une version extrêmement
expurgée des faits tels qu'ils se
seraient passées comme s'en souviendra
peut-être nathalie charron puisque je
faisais une une couverture pour votre
beauté j'ai reçu malheureusement
important de décor sur la figure qu'il
faut à peu près 70 kg en acier et je les
prie juste ici donc hôpital scanner
on termine tant bien que mal interview
les photos que l'on peu de travers avec
un chapeau sur la tête puis tu sais tout
est comme ça et nous rentrons à genève
et là à ce moment là je commence à me
sentir mal vertiges nausées je vais à
nouveau faire un scanner et on demande à
mon mari de ne pas me quitter parce que
je dors 20 heures par jour de ne pas me
quitter parce que je risque de tomber
dans le coma il va se passer quelque
chose de très extraordinaire de 7 heures
du matin à 1h du matin mon mari me
laissera seule sans manger sans boire il
fait très chaud nous sommes au mois
d'août et pendant deux jours d'affilée
ça se reproduit et le deuxième soir je
suis
interrogative et je mime quelqu'un qui
ne bougent plus voir ce qu'il va se
passer et mon mari arrivent à côté du
lit
et simplement y pousse ma main c'est ce
que veut dire cette simple phrase vous
en déduisez ce que vous voulez les
freins de la voiture qui lâche vous
serez très étonnant quand on a une
voiture qui est une rendu revers quand
on est envoyé en mission à monter à au
festival de cannes et qu'on a pour
mission apparemment de rencontrer
monsieur mouiller ou et de revenir avec
une certaine somme d'argent dont je
parlerai uniquement devant les juges
mais je suis heureuse de pouvoir le dire
à l'avance devant vous ce soir comme je
le ferai à chaque fois que j'irai voir
un juge je les fais et j'ai essayé de le
faire très souvent pendant huit ans
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la décision de
parler d'abord à la presse avant de me
présenter devant un juge de façon à ce
que l'opinion publique française soit au
courant de ce qui se passe c'est une
prothèse d'une certaine façon me
protéger je vais vous dire très
sincèrement je pense que j'aurai une
peau de banane qui glissera sous un
camion lequel sera écrasée par un avion
que j'aurai une balle dans la tête que
je serais suicidé je serai très déprimé
mais quoi qu'il en soit aujourd'hui j'ai
enfin la possibilité après huit ans de
dire ce à quoi nous avons tous à faire
face tous ici nous les français nous
avons à faire face est une organisation
extraordinairement dangereuse et le
gouvernement ne peut rien y faire alors
vous découvrez un jour que votre mari a
primé en assurance vie quand il est le
bénéficiaire si vous décédez vous
découvrez aussi d'autres choses
n'étaient pas tout étaler ici manche je
vous en prie faites le pas qu'il a des
relations homosexuelles avec un homme
politique internationale très connu vous
finissez par découvrir que les affaires
de votre mari s'en sont pas très claires
en fait c'est à dire que je ne découvre
rien du tout je j'ai tellement la
trouille que je fini par demander à des
gardes du corps de venir et en une heure
je viens mon mari je suis désolé je
resterai pas dans le même pièce que toi
sois tu vas à l'hôtel soit moi je vais à
l'hôtel mais c'est terminé j'ai eu trop
la trouille donc nous séparons très
abruptement il me laisse dans
l'appartement qu'il a mis à mon nom pour
une raison que j'ignore mais que les
juges j'espère comprendront mieux que
moi et je découvre là ce qui était
supposé être les archives de la charge
eric de l'avant des rats ce ne sont pas
des archives
ce sont des papiers et enfin son
ordinateur dans l'appartement notre
ordinateur dans un appartement qui est
en mon nom un autre ordinateur contient
effectivement
95 % de dossiers qui lui appartiennent
auquel je ne comprends rien pendant
quatre mois et au bout de quatre mois je
commence à découvrir la vérité et c'est
tout à fait tout à fait est
extraordinaire
et abominable on a dix qui refusait de
lui verser une pension alimentaire et
tout ce que vous disiez c'était
justement pour le forcer à vous la
verser effectivement j'ai demandé
pendant cinq ans il ya une demande
d'annulation de mariage qui a été
instruite cette demande d'annulation de
mariage dans la mesure où on annuler le
mariage ne vous donne pas droit à une
pension alimentaire s'est donc trouvé
que ça n'était pas le but premier au
jour d'aujourd'hui il est bien évident
que comme n'importe quelle femme qui a
été qu'ils divorcent je demande une
pension alimentaire mais effectivement
il ya quelque chose de très spécial je
demande une pension alimentaire élevée
qui est de l'ordre de 39 euros par mois
avec un mari qui annonce environ 3000
francs de salaire par mois j'espère avec
cette demande que le tribunal sera
suffisamment dans l'interrogation pour
se dire il faut faire une enquête sur
les revenus de monsieur de la vanéra
c'est tout ce que j'espère en demandant
aux jours d'un ancien amant terre c'est
que le tribunal enquête sur les revenus
de monsieur la mort des rats et je tiens
à dire au tribunal dès aujourd'hui que
j'ai de quoi l'informer voilà alors ce
qu'il faut lire effectivement c'est qu'à
l'automne dernier quand diego de l'avant
des rats se brouille avec son ami
antoine sous leurs fruits pas du tout il
se brouille pas du tout c'est son père
et ne fait de l'avant des rats qui
disent vous le foot est dehors
immédiatement c'est tout à fait
différent voulu recueillir évidemment il
est en chaussettes sur le palier qui
serait que je fasse je l' ai connu tout
petit vous lui dites à ce moment là j'ai
dit rien du tout ne dit pas la vérité
sur les affaires de son père de de
glisse ils sont ils sans doute cela dit
moi je suis sur un dossier de divorce
qui est en même temps effectivement une
affaire d'états et non pas une affaire
de pension alimentaire comme on a bien
voulu le dire et je lui ai je lui montre
mes dossiers parce qu'il est beaucoup
plus qu'avec moi dans l'ordinateur moi
je suis vraiment une panique totale donc
lui commence à naviguer et d'un coup il
a la révélation absolue qu'il y a comme
je le pense moi même effectivement 1
comment voient une organisation à
pionsat une organisation qui lie à une
organisation criminelle
qui en ce moment à peu près à sa
disposition de 250 fois le budget de la
france
j'estime aujourd'hui malheureusement sg
pas eu envie que ça me tombe sur la tête
et ça m'amuse pas et c'est pas mes
oignons et c'est pas mes affaires je
suis dans une autre vie une artiste et
je n'ai envie de m'occuper que de ça
mais il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui je me
lève pour dire faites attention vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans un extrême danger
alors évidemment depuis 8 ans tout le
monde dit que je suis une folle une
droguée en fait c'est comme catherine ci
est effectivement ça a été très
difficile aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
merci didier soulet j'ai la chance de
pouvoir faire entendre ce que j'ai à
dire c'est pas pour moi encore une fois
que je lui ai dit c'est vraiment c'est
pour vous on va justement maintenant
voir un petit peu tout ce qui vous est
reproché
on vous reproche de fréquenter antoine
soûlard et vous un personnage un peu
étrange un peu ambigu qui s'appelle
christian cotten qui s'est joint à vous
lui dit qu'il est psychosociologue
on le dit proche du mouvement sectaire
on le dit proche de l'extrême droite et
didier schuller d'ailleurs parle de
sectes fasciste européenne en ce qui le
concerne qui est cette question que tu n
es comment avez vous été en contact avec
lui antoine lui qui était toujours sur
l'ordinateur était en train de naviguer
comme on dit sur internet ce que je ne
vais pas faire et trouve un monsieur qui
a l'air de s'occuper très fort de
l'organisation du temple solaire ce qui
s'appelle organisation peut-être que
l'ordre du temple
à huy se trouve que malheureusement je
suis en mesure de donner des
informations puisque j'ai moi même et
c'est mon mari a essayé de m'entraîner
dans cette scène hardcore donc j'avais
deux ou trois détails et je me suis dit
dans le fond ce pauvre monsieur keller
de chercher des choses j'ai convoqué
monsieur cotten chez moi à paris je lui
donnais les informations qui étaient à
ma disposition puisque c'est mon
témoignage et que je peux le prouver je
lui donnais sa merci au revoir j'ai dit
antoine quand nous sommes rendrait tous
les deux à genève on arrête là c'est pas
la peine d'essayer avec les français
nous avions déjà envoyé un dossier à la
6ième aux webbys a l'air fou ce que je
dis ah ouais ça a l'air vraiment faute
avait alors on veut surtout faire taire
effectivement
soit vous faire passer pour ça qu'avec
ce que je raconte mais sincèrement me
raconterait une histoire comme ça mais
je suis la première à dire m'attend la
fille l épique et lé attend la vieille
chanteuse comme on dit non je sais pas
quoi elle et elle est malade elle est en
train de rab sauf que quand même quoi
qu'il en soit j'ai une masse de dossiers
qui ne sont pas écrits par mois c'est
bien évident j'ai une masse aujourd'hui
en l'espace de trois jours une seule est
un service internet je voudrais faire
parvenir s'il reste des juges en france
du monde me dit que vichnievsky est en
train de donner sa démission
on me dit qu eva joly donne sa démission
on a vu que monsieur halphen a donné sa
démission mais dites moi à qui on va
parler nous à moi dans l'intérêt je
crois que c'est ce qu'a laissé leur
comment ce que je fais alors antoine
sous leur dit lui aussi qu'il a reçu
beaucoup de menaces genre des coups de
fil du genre faudrait faire attention ne
pas traverser oui en dehors des clous 1
et on voit que c'est dangereux parce que
lui a dit ça il son père didier schuller
a déclaré si je me suicide faudra pas y
croire a déclaré ça avant de partir de
ça dommage qu'on va bien quand même
qu'on est dans un problème mafieux de sa
résidence non pour l'instant lui il est
dans un problème politique mais il est
évident que ce qui s'est passé au et
repérer au rpr à ce moment là je n'en
sais rien c'est pas mon problème je ne
connais pas didier soulet et j'en ai
rien oui
s'il donne chirac ou parce qu asus sont
deux problèmes alors antoine schuller
dit antoine schuller dit que son père va
parler du financement du rpr et qu'en
fait il parlera jamais des réseaux
supérieur qui contrôle tout ça alors
vous vous en parlait pas beaucoup mais
vous commencez à citer des noms vous
citer le nom de l'avant des rares
gagnants parlez vous citer le nom de
gobi et le nom de mimran comment vous
des français nous est alors c'est pas
des français bien sûr qu'ils sont des
françaises en rajouter deux tubes ice
cube ice j'ai franchement j non ça c'est
russe d'accord et morishita ces japonais
je tiens à dire aussi que
bienheureusement et d'une manière que je
n'attendais pas du tout depuis deux
jours à genève j'ai vu au moins quatre
hommes d'affaires extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement important qui m'ont amené
environ 25 kg dossier ouais je ne suis
pas seule il y as derrière moi et autour
de moi en ce moment des gens qui
spontanément vont venir dire ceux de
quoi ils ont été les témoins explique l
affaire elf explique l affaire de l'eau
ts sur le buzz mais ces textes mais
c'est hallucinant histoire c'est fou
c'est fou mais moi ça c'est qu'en fait
en fait au travers de ça on a toute une
meilleure de choses autour en famille
bien sûr mais c'est beau mais cela dit
je prends un risque énorme en venant ici
en venant à dire tout ça c'est que ça ne
m'amuse pas j'ai rien à vendre j'ai rien
à le déshonneur qui les en avaient de
quoi
je monte au créneau et je le ferai
incessamment ils ont vraiment fait
n'importe quoi avec mes enfants et ça je
le supporte pas la raison c'est la
raison de base quand c'est la raison de
base tous tous les cinq noms 1,4 à dire
que diego a été du goût de l'avant
guerre a été malade en fait il a eu un
cancer du poumon de deux cancers voilà
voilà un enfant qu'on soigne
27 ans
voilà un enfant qu'on soigne en lui
faisant des piqûres d'hormones mâles
et auquel on donne une somme de 400
mille francs par mois pour avoir accès à
toutes les drogues dont il a envie
quand on l'envoie dans un centre ici à
paris il tombe sur un sur un psychiatre
qui lui dit tu en fais pas poko je suis
franc maçon tu peux tu me dire il sait
très bien qu'il est dans les mains de
son père comment voulez vous que cet
enfant puisse venir à la surface puisse
exprimer ce qu'il a à dire puis sortir
de la drogue et du désarroi dans lequel
il est il n'a pas le droit de me parler
alors que vous l'avez lever les levées
il n'a pas le droit depuis une de 94 il
n'a pas le droit de parler quand il me
parle il ya la révolution et didier
schuller notre à paris vous le croyez ça
et mon problème c'est que c'est louable
mais j'ai du mal à avoir de la peine
pour pour cet homme là quoi parce que au
niveau parce que je connais à 12 il
n'habite pas loin
d'hama de la peine parce qu'il a quatre
cent mille balles par
moi non plus c'est pas ça qui me fait
pleurer on est bien d'accord cela dit
son problème reste le même est-ce qu'on
se rappelle quand même qu'il ya que 4 %
de la pollution de la population
mondiale qu'un à toi déjà c'est
exactement pour cela que je me bats si
t'as pas compris que c'est pour cela que
je me parle enfin de
faire péter cette saloperie de 2,2 mafia
de merde sur la conjoncture j'ai un
problème un peu mais je peux comprendre
mais c'est pour eux que je me bats je
veux pas qu'on ait la révolution je veux
simplement avertir les gens leur dit
vous voyez bien qu'il se passe des
choses bizarres il ya des gens -
chaussée et ça ça n'a rien eu c'est
repoussé et puis l'hôte et s on n'a pas
pu sont des gens qui se suicident avec
notre balles dans le corps mais on nous
prend pour des cons mais le v vous nom
d'un chien levé vous et les venez dire
mais arrêtez de nous prendre pour des
cons c'est pas vrai il se passe quelque
chose j'ai pas envie d'être là ça me
fait chier mais je suis obligé de le
faire
tu comprends mieux
ce soir encore un truc aussi personnelle
bordel des maires s'étaient mariés la
foire est quand même ouais voilà non
parce qu'il ya quand même un truc on
entend qu'on entend moi qui maillent qui
m'a quand même marqué puis je pense la
marque et où les princesses ces juges
qui démissionnent est actée départ que
parce que les bécasses rabou quoi un
sens quand je vais voir les juges ils
sont pas à bout
rester avec nous
alors maintenant j'ai un petit peu ça
c'est un petit peu de ton avant alors je
redeviens vous avec maria pas si vous
voulez on a changé un peu de temps mais
avant de recevoir françois léotard qui
lui aussi avait affaire à des affaires a
besoin est avec des papes en tant que
voilà
françois léotard ça faisait longtemps
que j'avais pas fais une émission il y
avait des politiques ou et des histoires
parce que là j'ai maintenant je leur
fait peur maintenant donc très moi tu me
fais plus que là c'est pas pour souffler
qu'une paille en regardant le cul mais
bravo
a quand même tu me ferait presque un
compliment la voilà
mais
je vous demande de vous
j'ai pas vu les bons sens pas
bien alors avant de passer un françois
léotard qui lui aussi a eu affaire à pas
mal pas mal d'histoires dans lesquels on
a essayé de l'entraîner etc et vous
expliquera tout ça il nous parlera aussi
de son dernier livre qui est en même
temps son premier roman on va recevoir
titoff quand même parce que tu avais un
peu plus
toi
oui on l'a effectivement d'arrivée
moelle arrive quand la bonne ambiance
j'ai entendu un petit peu là on arrive à
ses forces et fort par quitter comme ça
marianne sous l'ère hu est
pas mal pour un maître du sud dakar
parisien du nord contre
alors titoff après 122 tournée dans
toute la france vous terminez à
marseille
france et je finis c'est un petit peu
normal à la bande annonce est une
tradition donc voilà j'ai hâte d'y être
titoff
je sais que c'est nul en promo ouais
enfin je sais pas vous allez faire des
petits pains un
vraiment le plus beau rêve de ma vie
mais vraiment au plus profond de moi tu
vois serait d'aider les jeunes en
difficulté j'ai pas la voiture
alors je vous fous rien de la journée
un événement heureusement j'ai ma
passion est là à la masturbation
la la masturbation et de ce qui s'est
passé mais une telle crainte de patients
instables j'ai pas qu'on souvent
l'occasion de la montagne
par contre je n'ai pas connu lorsque le
froid dit c'est que je le prenais tout
le monde instaure des jouets à quelqu'un
faire du stop je le prenais bon niveau
j'étais un peu pressé on ce que je
faisais quand vous arrivez comme ça avec
la voiture mais je ne veux m'arrêter
pour ça et quelques élèves au niveau de
la voiture en s'assurant des marques
sur le coup j'en faisais gagné 300 400 m
ce que l'on me faisait sa
note qui marche bien que tu fais les
somistes les médicaments elle et les
somnifères le fusil efficace et les
somnifères insu positivement c'est plus
efficacement si c'est trop forte et trop
rapide
moi j'ai essayé une fois je ne m'étais
jamais convaincu
c'est trop beau
c'est trop rapide matin ce que j'ai dit
non
je sais ce que c'est kim a déréglé le
changement d'heure d'hiver l'arrière
front quatre semaines qu'est ce que tu
veux et enfants ne respectent plus assez
la nature
mais le monde devient
alors bravo lors d'un 50 millions
d'années à plus de couche d'ozone et
personne ne dit rien qu'est ce que
le monde devient fou c'est une
invitation pour une soirée mondaine
je m'insurge être bien vas-y est bon je
savais pas trop comment m'habiller ce
que j'ai fait j'ai téléphoné une copine
a manqué un peu l'habitude et est tout
de suite elle m'a dit ah oui tu vas une
soirée mondaine là la grande mode en ce
moment dans ce milieu c'est de madrid et
pascal avec un constat gb merci beaucoup
à un moment j'ai cherché tout l'après
midi comme un fou des costards des
costards je n'ai pas trouvé de costa
lorsque j'ai fait moi je suis allé un
choix la souris verte quel est mon cas
c'est
c'est minable
associé me simon papa maman
non qu'ils font
il conseille notamment mieux
titeuf
extrait du dvd la vhs de son spectacle
tique un peu dames messieurs
alors tu t'offres
beaucoup de mails que je reçois rapporte
un comportement un petit peu délictueux
dans les villes de la tournée est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous repentir oui
interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
titoff oui quand j'étais petit as tu
essayé de regarder sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
ouais
mais justement c'était ça le problème
c'est comment voyez que la culotte en
fait titeuf
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin
dans les cabinets mais ça donc je le
faisais pas petit mais maintenant
j'essaye des fois d'enfermer les nanas
dans les chiottes est ce que tu te robe
pas en titoff sur sa non mais tu
n'entrera pas au paradis ah merde
titoff véhicules récemment
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété
pour obtenir des avantages particuliers
oui je peux répondre à sa place ou moins
grave grave funes gags en boîte mais
comme sahin carré viiip je regarde jeu
mais là je fais coucou à tout le monde
et
tu obtiens les avantages particuliers a
déjà servi qu'à faire le guet c'est
super mais tu t'en rends bien sur obiwi
42 toit en gironde titoff dans ces cas
là as-tu exigé de tes partenaires des
pratiques contre nature
contre nature non jamais jamais t'es con
titoff ces actes délictueux ont ils
étaient accompagnés par l'absorption de
substances illicites way jamais jamais
titoff oui dans ces cas là quand tu as
pris ces substances ne t'appartient plus
il m'appartient
peter oui parce que tu as pris ces
substances illicites tu ne t'appartient
plus est ce que tu penses que l'on
puisse aimer une femme
et la tâche et la foule était
justement passé parce qu'on aime si on
fait ça si tu veux entrer au paradis
titeuf dis moi maintenant je me repens
je me repens
[Musique]
demain ne glandent titoff donc je peux
aller au paradis ah oui oui ça j'ai pas
fait de trop en fait quand même la
galène qui m'a envoyé un mail n'était
pas contente pas mal j'accueille
maintenant françois léotard
bonsoir c'est marie laforêt titoff joey
starr est mon ami comme si lisa
thauvette
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle pour parler de votre livre en
premier alors
vous connaissez joey starr
j'ai subi en juin 96 lorsque marchiani
le préfet du var obtient que ntm soit
déprogrammé du festival dans le var je
suis le seul à l'avoir défendu vous
protestez qui était prise je suis
d'accord je ne sais pas mais si c'est là
la raison est la vraie raison pour
laquelle quand même je sers la mort aux
shadoks à côté de moi c'est que c'est
que je suivais son frère ouais c'est
beaucoup ce qu'il a protesté c'est vrai
françois léotard a protesté non mais
j'ai l'impression de le croire sincère
c'est vrai il a protesté de façon
marquée nice n'est pas sans quoi parle
donc de toutes façons jusque faisait mme
arkani protesté bon copain qui voit là
c'est un copain pasqua marchiani oui
c'est pas à l'examen c'est ce que je
voulais mais cinq mois plus tard quand
même c'est un petit peu varié vous avez
estimé que la condamnation quand même
été assez mauvaise que ça et voilà ce
qu'il avait fait un truc sait plus quoi
mais quoi toi que j'ai pu faire je
faisais rire ma musique et moi et c'est
deux choses quand même bien je vous
assure un conseiller vous puisque c'est
une soirée très serré la main ouais va
très bien alors françois léotard vous
avez arrêté définitivement la politique
qu'est man truck il a arrêté il a dit
j'ai fait le tour j'arrête et fin
décembre 2001 vous avez été nommé
inspecteur général des finances a nommé
en conseil des ministres par chirac il
avait accepté par jeunesse paris n'a pas
arrêté il a abandonné tous ses mandats
politiques je crois que le dernier que
je l'abandonné c'est député du var vous
étiez élu sans arrêt depuis depuis des
lui cinq ans depuis 25 ans et vous avez
arrêté donc maintenant il a plus de
fonctions politiques françois le terreau
n'est plus un homme politique on va voir
c'est à plus tard des finances
instructeurs des finances justement
qu'est ce que c'est expliquez-nous
françois quand j'ai fait les naja
pouvait j'étais je suis entré dans la
préfectorale après j'étais élu pendant
25 ans et là je retourne dans
l'administration c'est l'administration
c'est pas la même chose quand on est
dans la vie politique on est élu par
l'administration n'est nommé et c'est
vraiment le pays en même temps 1
mon avis moi que qui six mois deux mois
oui c'est vrai que j'allais dire je
voulais on a vu à la fois c'est normal
ça gagne on peut le dire aussi puisqu'on
dit tout ça gagne 60 musicale par mois
inspecteurs des films aujourd'hui pas là
j'ai commencé il ya un mois j'en suis là
mais qu'est-ce qu'on alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on est inspecteur jour
je vais respecter la douane de saint
malo hu est arrivé vous inspectés ouais
ouais ouais on arrive on discute avec
les gens on regarde ce qui se passe on
regarde s'il travaille bien s'il arrive
alors le matin si
donc aujourd'hui françois léotard êtes
soumis à un devoir de réserve on peut
dire quand même que vous êtes plutôt
favorables à mme chirac à bayrou
ouais je dirais même pas ça je veux dire
que j'ai des convictions depuis 30 ans
j'ai jamais changé et je suis pas à
gauche il faut dire les choses de façon
négative ça c'est vrai mais voilà je
m'arrête là
chirac plutôt que bayrou mais c'est oui
c'est quoi l'alternative mais chirac
bayeux dès lundi les centristes c'est
béraud qu'espèrent ses voilà voilà et
puis à des centristes qui sont pour bear
ou d'un coq et des centristes qui sont
pour chirac comme douste-blazy par
exemple alors en tous les cas françois
léotard
a déclaré ya vingt ans donc c'est pas un
propos de circonstance était en 92 et
déclaré j'ai toujours eu le sentiment
que la littérature c'était vrai c'est
qu'est le monde réel et que le reste
étaient faux donc c'est pas nouveau 1 et
pourtant à l'époque que vous avez
déclaré ça vous étiez en plein dans la
politique c'est une époque était très
importante pour vous et si votre père
andré léotard qui vous a branché sur la
littérature ils vous disent et votre
père une journée passée sans lire est
une journée perdue enfin qu'on lit un
livre par je revois la france à la
hauteur j'ai déjà publié huit livres
mais c'est votre premier roman c'est
comment on fait john contre lui on fait
quoi
personne
ne peut faire que ça oui attention un
deux trois
bien aux religieux françois léotard
s'appelle la couleur des femmes c'est
chez grasset alors françois léotard
pourquoi la couleur des femmes parce que
le narrateur qui est pas le quai par
l'écrivain inquiets mais le narrateur la
personne qui parle avec un jeudi ou qui
que quand il voit une femme il connaît
tout de suite ses couleurs il devine
tout de suite sa couleur est un des
fameux violette et par les femmes rose
défait par les femmes bleues celles qui
l'aiment et celle qu'ils rencontrent
pour la première fois enfin si j'ose
dire il beaucoup plus âgé qu'elle c'est
une jeune palestinienne elle et elle est
brune et il y tout est brun en elle son
regard son visage son corps et elle a
une espèce de autour d'elle comme un
silence qui est lui-même brun et il sent
la couleur des femmes et 10 g menu des
femmes verte qui étaient comme des
prairies au bord de la mer et et il a un
sens de la il aime les femmes il aime
les femmes et il les connaît par cette
couleur qu'elle est quelle qu'elle est
exprimée alors le pitch qu'est ce qui se
passe au pays rigoler
je racontais le ce que raconte libre je
vais essayer le pitch comme on dit ici
donc c'est roméo et juliette à c'est
david qui est fils de rabbin qui est une
espèce d'éternel étudiant qui rendent
contre sonia qui est violoniste
d'origine palestinienne ils sont le
contraire l'un de l'autre et ils vont
s'aimer jusqu'au jour où elle décide
brutalement de rompre voilà alors
pourquoi avoir pris un héros juif j'ai
toujours eu je me suis engagé dans la
vie politique à cause de la choix parce
que j'ai considéré que c'était ce qu'il
y avait dans l'histoire du monde dans
l'histoire humaine ce qui avait de pire
mais que c'était hier et que donc il
sort de l'idée du progrès lui-même l
étude c'est une idée qui m'est assez
étrangère je pense que que l'homme
l'humanité l'humain peut peut continuer
aujourd'hui à torturer à tuer a fusillé
à pendre françois léotard ce livre parle
de la guerre et vous qui vous vivez en
héros romantique est ce que ça vous a
manqué finalement ne pas avoir pu vivre
l'aventuré d'une guerre je suis dans une
génération où on voulait tous est jean
moulin ouais bon français on se disait
au fond c'est qu'il ya quelque chose si
de nouveaux ça revenait c'est ça qu'il
faudrait faire puis voilà on est on est
arrivé après la guerre d'algérie en fait
et donc dieu merci pour pour la france
pour ce pays il n'ya pas une guerre dans
la génération à laquelle j'appartiens
dieu merci bon donc moi j'ai pas connu
proprement pensée celle que je vois un
cul comme ministre vous pensez que la
politique en temps de paix c'est quelque
chose d'assez superficielle finalement
et que ça vous a manqué ça ne pas avoir
une je pense que tout ça que j'avais
demandé à leurs macédoine par exemple
oui oui parce que parce que là il y
avait de nouveau le tragique et que je
savais très bien pour être allé souvent
en bosnie à sarajevo que ça pouvait
recommencer là et que tout ce qu'on
avait fait comme efforts avec les
blessés et les morts réussissant blessés
nous aurions que celui des français
j'accompagnais chacun d'entre eux les
types qui étaient amputés qui était
défigurée et caetera et et je crois
qu'ils font il fallait éviter que ça
continue ou plutôt que ça recommence son
sens inverse ça s'est arrêté je suis
arrêté on a réussi
alors en fait françois léotard le david
eux le héros de votre roman écrit
l'histoire 25 ans après les faits et
c'est là qu'il part rencontré sept les
lacs et la soeur donc de sonia qu'il
avait beaucoup aimé à l'époque avant
leur rupture
il lui fait intrants et elle meurt dans
un attentat contre un bus et est ce que
finalement le fait d'avoir été pro
palestiniens dans votre jeunesse est ce
que c'est pas ça qui vous a ramené vers
ça que je me souviens de toutes les
guerres qui se sont passées là bas à
chaque fois j'ai traduit mon
mon admiration pour l'état d'israël
chaque fois parce que je considérais que
c'était un peuple menacé et je trouve
que maintenant effectivement le conflit
d'aujourd'hui est terrible parce que
chacun a raison et comment départager
des gens qui se chassent l'un l'autre de
la même terre est presque delà des mêmes
racines qui sont tous des enfants
d'abraham ouais c'est extrêmement
difficile de dire voilà ceux là ont
raison ceux là ont tort et je pensais
que l'amour en train d'être entre deux
êtres humains une petit arabe et un juif
cet amour là pouvaient transcender les
langues les cultures les religions
les histoires l'humus l'épaisseur des
histoires et et je pense que c'est
encore possible ouais je pense que quand
un être humain m une autre personne il
peut traverser toute une série
d'obstacles que malheureusement la
logique de l'histoire c'est la guerre un
essai de les empêcher de s'aimer
alors on va parler un peu de vous parce
que finalement je me rends compte qu on
vous connaît assez mal
[Applaudissements]
alors c'était en 1942 il ya bientôt 60
ans famille de sept enfants dont votre
frère philippe léotard acquis le livret
est dédié alors que vous étiez ministre
de la défense il disait moi je suis
ministre de la défonce ça définit assez
bien le personnage
tout est dit alors vous êtes corse par
votre mère et vous descendez de la soeur
de charlemagne sage évoqué de me prenais
mon père s'appelle charlemagne avait une
soeur de charles manic son demi-frère ya
pas de charlemagne qui est parti
évangéliser la corse et votre père
j'espère que vous le savez votre père et
parents du clown léotard vous le savez
ça il y avait un léotard qui étaient
cloués à leuthard qui est écoutée
l'inventeur du résiste trapèze volant
et le sais plus mais au tard a été
l'inventeur du justaucorps pour les
danseuses et en anglais en anglais on
dit toujours ce qui veut dire aller au
tas alors votre père françois léotard
était maire de fréjus et il ya eu en
1959 à fréjus une grande catastrophe que
la rupture du barrage de malpasset ce
qui fait que tout là toute la région a
été inondé il ya eu beaucoup de morts
votre père a été calomnié on a parlé de
détournement de fonds publics destinés à
la reconstruction de la région est ce
que serait pas pu savourer guérir de la
politique est ce que finalement
voyant comment votre père était
calomniée pourquoi vous êtes pas dit la
politique c'est de la merde j vais pas à
quoi c'est l inverse assez marrant parce
que mes origines corses ont fait que
quand il est mort je me suis dit cela
ceux qui ont fait ça je les avoir ils
vont raser les murs vous avez dit ouais
ouais et c'est ce qui s'est passé ouais
je sais c'est bizarre je trouve que la
vengeance un très beau sentiment son
côté corse non mais c'est pas vrai on
nous a tous enseigné que ce n'est pas
bien moi je vous sais très bien tu es
d'accord
je suis assez d'accord bien alors
fonctionne le tacon city adolescente
étiez plutôt à gauche vous étiez ps sur
68 vous je tiens avec votre frère des
pots de fleurs sur les crs alors des
choses oui c'est marrant parce que dit
on comprime condamné après
on dirait que vous avez prêté jeunes
sénégalais demba ba pasqua vous apprêtez
jeune quoi oui mais c'est vrai ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'à un moment où la
générosité la volonté de révolte
l'esprit de révolte l'emportent sur le
reste quand vous êtes jeune et que vous
n'êtes pas révoltés pour adecco je veux
dire que si si si quand on a 20 ans on
n'est pas en révolte contre une société
contre ce cas là d' injuste de mal foutu
dire c'est assez bizarre et moi j'étais
comme ça c'est vrai j'étais comme ça
donne après que j'ai changé parce que
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait que ça soit
cette société là elle marchait fort
myers 1 qu'il fallait la faire
fonctionner ce qui prouve à quel point
vous étiez enquête cet âge là à cette
époque là c'est qu'à l'âge de 22 ans
vous partez dans un monastère sous le
nom de frère honorât vous devenez un
moine bénédictin au couvent de la pierre
qui vit on se lève la nuit ont fait des
prières en pleine nuit donc ça prouve
quand même qu'à cette époque là vous
aviez un vrai un vrai désir d'absolu et
de silence rape à ce qu un escabeau dans
la vie monastique c'est le silence ne me
dit rien vous parlez pas et pendant un
an j'ai pas parlé il a entendu ça fait
du bien ça c'est fabuleux mais
alors voilà on venait en fait quand même
l'ena et vous êtes toujours de gauche
parce que vous créez la première section
syndicale de la cfdt à l'ena en 74 ou
voter pour le président mitterrand alors
pourquoi après vous êtes devenu de
droite pour réussir leur arrivisme non
c'est giscard je vais vous dire c'est
marrant quand giscard a commencé sa vie
politique enfin par l'élection
présidentielle j'ai eu le sentiment evry
lloris n'est pas le seul dans l'été
nombreux puisqu'il a été élu pensé qu'il
était moderne il apportait dans la vie
politique française qui était très
archaïque des sentiments de modernité
des éléments de modernité c'était
d'ailleurs l'avortement avec simone veil
et c est et sera de vote pour les jeunes
le droit de vote pour les jeunes femmes
beaucoup de choses sa façon d'être son
comportement et rsa je reconnais à l'âge
que j'avais à ce moment là ça m'a séduit
puis j'ai les suivis après pendant
jusqu'à maintenant bah oui oui vous avez
été extrêmement virulent 80 quand la
gauche est arrivée au pouvoir les quatre
ministres communistes alors que l'urss
existait encore c'est pas comme
maintenant et puis il ya eu ce qu'on
appelle la bande à léo ça a été un petit
peu votre apogée avec madelin longuet
douffiagues qui lui aussi d'ailleurs
arrêté la politique complètement vous
êtes 2 sur 4 pratiquement trois sur
quatre est lancée l'époque on a parlé du
temps des quadras il y avait michel
rivet toute cette bande de gens carignon
et ça n'a pas marché pourquoi vous êtes
planté parce que vous vouliez renouveler
la vie politique à l'époque il y avait
des volonté de réformer ce qui me frappe
le plus dans la vie politique française
ce cce comment dire son caractère de
fermer c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas
le système américain vous faites pas
plus que deux mandats et de manado
aximum de 4 ans puis après vous allez
dans un gros dans une entreprise
éventuellement vous revenez en france
donner des gens de 75 ans qui continue à
se présenter et qui sont là depuis 30 35
40 ans est ce que vous n'avez pas été à
la hauteur de vos ambitions ou c'est la
france qui n'a pas été à la hauteur de
vos ambitions je crois que j'ai mis 25
ans à savoir ou à deviner que j'aimais
pas le pouvoir ouais c'est très étrange
mais des gens comme ça qui découvrent
tardivement qu'il serait véritablement
mais je crois qu'au fond le pouvoir ça
qu'auront ça tue ça vous il a démoli et
voilà et puis j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre ça et vous citiez mon frère
tout à l'heure je crois que c'est lui
qui avait raison au fond c'est parler
beau but qui avait raison je crois
vraiment à bordel non mais je veux dire
dans le champ du tout de le dire dans le
fond c'est bien qu'il le reconnaît à
soral pas de tous les choix de sa vie le
neuf et qu'il a choisi spécifiquement
pour là puisqu'il vient de dire jusque
et une vie de liberté qui est une vie de
bronze d'insolence jeu prox
raison se trouve zic plein de problèmes
s'est opposé à pasqua
c'est la sphère du chartered et 101
maliens vous étiez contre
deuxième problème en 95 choisissez
balladur et chirac mauvaise pioche
vous étiez peut-être aussi trop anti
front national pour le parti républicain
qui est finalement un parti où il ya pas
mal de gens qui sont pas d'extrême
droite mais bien la droite quand même
hein on voit ce qui est devenu
démocratie libérale et puis vous avez
aussi des affaires sur le dos pas mal
d'affaires le mur de votre propriété de
fréjus sur le cac gloser pour lesquels
n'y a jamais eu un seul une seule
condamnation du narcisse sinon je
viendrai pas au contraire j'ai fait
condamner les générations ça veut pas
dire que vous n'êtes pas forcément c'est
aussi à fortiori quand on a passé a
fortiori quand ouais d'accord c'est en
tous les cas vos adversaires qui ont été
condamnés pour diffamation les ducs lui
si il ya eu l'affairé yann piat où elle
a été assassinée alors vous a carrément
accusé d'avoir été à l'origine du
meurtre
avec gaudin c'est la fameuse affaire de
long corner de trottinettes et est
finalement ben là aussi vous avez
attaqué pour diffamation et la plus
grande cruz jô et vern et deux hauteurs
de google ont été condamnés c'est la
plus forte condamnation pénale qu'on et
j'ai pu obtenir sur des journalistes des
gens qui se qualifie de journalistes un
million de francs ouais
et puis vous avez toujours une affaire
sur le dos quand même c'est pas réglé
c'est la sphère de l'achat du siège du
parti réduit l'écart rue de constantine
est une banque italienne qui l'a acheté
et qui dit l'argent génie dans la chatte
ce siège du parti républicain rick
constantine monsieur
nous l'a apportée en coupure de 500
balles l'instruction a été close la
demande du parquet et c'est qu'un
vraisemblable d'ailleurs parce que ça
commence à bien faire ça fait maintenant
cinq six ou sept ans je sais plus que on
attend que des affaires soient de soirée
soient terminés soit close et ça vous
êtes devant des situations qui sont
insupportables pour une porte quel
justiciable pour l'armée entre nous il
ya une banque italienne qui achètent le
siège du parti républicain rue de
constantine cette banque dit le pognon
nous qu'on a donnée pour acheter on nous
l'a apportée en coupure de 500 francs
gemecs du parti républicain disent oui
c'est des fonds secrets quand la garder
à l'époque de matignon était relié son
c'est une décision qui a été prise à 30
30 autour d'une table dire vraiment ici
à 32 des voyous 30 gangster ça se sait
et moi j'étais le moment est
probablement celui qui savait le moins
comment ça s'est passé ouais si vous
n'êtes pas juge si mes souvenirs sont
bons ça je le dis aux juges et à mon
avis ça va bien avec s'intéresser qu'à
la main de la démocratie libérale à
attaquer les gens voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on doute
je suis solidaire de l'achat de ce siège
mais il se trouve que lui il transforme
le nom s'appelle pris le parti
républicain ouais nouvelle démocratie
libérale et il attaque voilà c'est pour
ça que je pose dernière journée raison
ce que je n'aime pas vraiment parce que
ça c'est insupportable
si les jugements rendus en trois minutes
à la télévision et alors une des raisons
c'est le tard une des raisons de votre
retrait du jeu politique c'est aussi vos
ennuis de santé parce que vous étiez un
marathonien émérite et un jour on vous
fait un triple pontage coronarien c'est
il faut pas faire de jogging
si vous j'ai beaucoup aimé ce ainsi 6
mai mais peut-être pas en faire trop
puis c'est le stress soit cette fois
vous avez un stress vous avez la vienne
qui se qui se resserre mais des clubs
aussi par un concours comme ça ouais
alors ça j'évitais mais moi j'ai fait ça
mais le stress mais ça existe et donc
donc çà çà çà çà la longue et si je
pouvais je pourrai récupérer le vélo
qu'elle abat après là c'est suite
drucker pour tu files de la face à
l'avenir le savoir c'est pour mickaël
plan le maquis en taule à roda français
de retard est-ce que vous avez pas été
victime finalement d'un désenchantement
progressif oui oui oui quelques fois on
comment dire on a on a envie de d'abord
une envie d'avoir plusieurs vies dans sa
vie bonjour ça bien de suivre ses désirs
de faire ce qu'on a envie de faire et je
pense pas qu'il ne se vit donc ça j'en
ai un peu fait le tour c'est vrai les
gens sont plus ou moins bien comme bon
donc voilà j'ai envie de connaître
d'autres gens de faire d'autres choses
le malade est de pouvoir de pour être
considéré comme un citoyen ordinaire ça
c'est formidable est tranquille là en
tout cas beaucoup plus heureux et ça
c'est vrai
françois léotard est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir raté votre vie non
si c'était à refaire je referais
n'entreprenne appareil à peu près d'un
autre chose
on rallume
françois le faire la couleur des femmes
ça premier roman chez grasset
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant on va faire un
anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
ancien notaire si vous étiez un défaut
vous sur lesquels des faux
jeu je suis myope ouais c'est formidable
quand on est bien vous êtes dans la même
pièce que didier schuller et vous le
voyez pas ça faisait des emplettes pas
mieux si vous étiez un accident
dégueulasse j'ai fait un accident
naturel peut-être j'ai rêvé d'être un
raz-de-marée parce que la mer ont dû
fait seul avaler tellement de choses
quand même quelques axes revanche si
vous étiez une perversion
le voyeur le voyeurisme j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien rentrer voir les gens
comme ça comment il veut dans la tête
wei dans leur tête mais aussi de chez
eux ça j'adore rsa une bouche si vous
étiez une guerre
la norme gri débarquement en normandie
ça c'était il y avait des français qui
ont débarqué là où l'un des fusilliers
marins qui ont débarqué en normandie les
premiers les premiers sur la plage de
riva-bella et beaucoup sont morts c'est
vrai que c'était très beau si vous étiez
une arme
un opinel mon truc comme ça pour le figa
tel écoute aux portes alors un supplice
un
très beau supplice
que j'ai en tête qui est celui de
tantale mais il est dans l'eau et puis
l'eau arrive jusque là il a soif je
propose qu'on replace le par du goudron
d'année ou par les un petrus un très bon
bordeaux c'est une cicatrice
je vais pas vous la montrer mais je suis
ouvert de la jusque là oui c'est la
meilleure et j'aime bien je la touche
alors la touche si vous étiez une [__]
ou sur l'équipe moi j'aime pas le mot
parce que j'ai jamais dit ça une femme
mais
bon dommage pourtant en soit chacun son
truc mais j'ai jamais dit ça il fane
jamais c'est à chacun son truc c'est on
est tous comme ça t'en marais voilà je
pensais je pensais à simone signoret
dans les diaboliques n'en avait pas la
personne la mairie
personnages ou madame de merteuil dans
les liaisons dangereuses une femme qui
fait des trucs extraordinaires mondiale
bolik mais qui arrive à faire affaire
tué son amant par la maîtresse de 7 à
mon sujet si vous étiez un dictateur
quel dictateur seriez-vous
j'aime pas ça je pense que vous savez
charlie chaplin quand ils jouent avec il
s'appelle de dictature les wii avec un
ballon qui est le monde c'est pas drôle
si vous n'êtes jamais voulu qu'on me
pose ces questions là mais on peut être
les poser son soutien on va se la poser
à toi la prochaine si vous étiez une
torture
indivise tête à tête avec la reine
d'angleterre ah oui
c'est les oreilles si vous étiez une
torture moi je vois pas le reste des
mythes ou alors si j'étais une torture
je m'appellerai cocaïne par exemple
voilà
ça c'est une vraie réponse est immédiate
c'est pour ça que des questions en bois
de tout à l'heure là
macha voilà un dictateur ou autres
avaient envie de jouer là si vous étiez
un terroriste vous seriez qui comme
terroriste un mec qui roule en ferrari
et qu'il s'arrête pas quand ou si vous
étiez une injure vous seriez quelle
injure on va manger la culotte à ta
vieille
si vous étiez une cuillère version jeune
star g-star en forme ouais vous êtes en
forme là si vous étiez à vis à vis
à vis je dirai comment il s'appelle
l'autre était même michael youn ouais
parce que quelque part sur un vice c'est
le morning live sur m6 tous les matins à
la mémé c'est même pas pour lui faire
une haie en quoi que ce soit si je suis
pas démago moi c'est vraiment parce que
je le crois il a mal quelque part si
vous étiez une arme si j'étais une arme
ni ta mère mais avec pas chez sony mais
si vous étiez une mort enfin un truc
bien horrible la tête dans une baignoire
parce que veut on veut que je dise où je
vais mon mag ou
un truc ridicule brouette je m'arrête à
mourir pour savoir d'accord qui sur la
tête blablabla et on permet de sourds ça
franchement ça c'est pire que de te
brûler les pieds ou parce que parce que
le gaz ou des choses comme ça bon
d'accord un moment d'inconscience et 1 6
8 points là c'est vraiment c
sait on peut te l'a serrée et le corps
humain est trop bien fait ça de refaire
le monde et tu perds conscience ouais
mais quand on te noies
c'est claustrophobie ces mêmes ceux qui
savent pas ce que c'est après las moment
france soir si vous étiez de mort d'un
mois dans mon livre je cite une marque
est très belle à un moment il raconte la
mort de kafka qu'elle est très belle
parce qu il vraiment de la morphine il
et il est en train de mourir c'est
d'abord lui tu attends attends ils
demandent de la morphine le type ans n'a
pas oublié n'y en a pas il dit cette
phrase extraordinaire dit tuez moi sinon
vous êtes un assassin
des mots
françois léotard la couleur des femmes
c'est chez grasset
ce n est pas à son premier livre b 6
bon
en soit merci d'être venu je vais vous
laisser guider merci merci a bientot
merci à chacun et bon courage chouchou
belle carrière
alors avant de placer à l'indiquer
suivant quelques mails joue au théâtre
ce soir c'est ça c'est ça les corses ont
dérogé à des usines
bien alors on passe aux mails enfin des
nouvelles des deux blondes de grenoble
katia ebéné qui ont définitivement
renoncé aux culottes et qui veulent les
vendre au profit de michaël blanc on
verra ça tout à l'heure hélène ségara
qui est séquestré par le talibans
orlando alors il ya un email de marco
clem de montréal qui lui au moins ne
risque rien et il ya un email de jérôme
biwa de libreville qui annonce la
création du clash alors le clash c'est
le collectif pour la libération l'aide
et le soutien à hélène ségara voilà
alors on passe à l'étranger on a des
mails de la plata en argentine
ignace you on a des mails de saint
pierre et miquelon de stéphane ai dit je
peux je peux moi je moi je voulais je
veux offrir à la dame qui en face de moi
désolé j'en ai pas pour toi jéjé de
marque de vêtements on a plus subversif
l'air de rien on s'appelle comme eight
vous offrez un petit pull je sais pas si
vous le mettrez oui mais c'est de votre
âge génial votre maman était une fan de
marie laforêt imaginant au moins un au
moins donc ça fait doit aussi un gardien
de la culture très bien mais ravive
encore
on continue
on continue les mêmes de l'étranger
salim ben ali de dubaï fernando les vies
de rio est donc merci tv5 parce que
grâce à tv5 cette émission est vu dans
80 pays et vous savez que si vous avez
raté le début de tout le monde en parle
sur france 2 vous pouvez voir l'émission
après la diffusion de cette émission sur
tv5 voilà alors un message pour lydia de
l'île faut persévérer
acquis annoncé une fille elle veut pas
persévéré moi je lui dis faut persévérer
ah c'est toi qui lui dit c'est moi qui
lui ai dit il faut faire c'est vrai ça
valait charles beer s'évalue sial en
quoi je peux pas le dire d'accord un
message pour emilie
faut essayer
pourquoi la prostitution c'est pas la
constitution mais c'est sexuel d'accord
parce que c'est pas loin un message de
fatima de toulouse qui dit le samedi
soir mon mari est absent je suis nue sur
le canapé
alors
alors regarde l'avenir la regarde la
regarder à gauche au delà et alors tu
habites où
est alors pour finir vincent girardi de
cormeilles-en-parisis
alors lui c'est terrible il dit je
voudrais que tu dises à tout le monde
que j'ai une petite [__] 13 cm en
érection c'est vrai que c'est pas
beaucoup mais dix jours et que tu le dis
parce que les filles aiment les petites
[__] les filles belles courses de
mammouth
je reçois maintenant helena noguerra
bella messieurs
il ya de la meuf franchement franchement
c'est bien franchement que demande le
peuple pas l'opulence enfin que
souffrance donc voila c'était de la
merde t'es content moi aussi alors au
gabon soir beaucoup d'actu pour vous en
ce moment donc je vous propose tout de
suite de faire quatre fois pomme parce
que comme il ya quatre actu ça sera
réglé allons-y alors j'ai une foi
de faim
or
catoire
je peux le faire juste pour moi j'espère
et voilà alors il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs pour vous d'abord il
ya un single extrait de votre album
[Musique]
j
ça c'est la première promo ensuite à
deux concerts au trianon les 12 et 13
février c'est pourquoi c'est une star
des films de cul ouais c'est ça un pays
qu un vieux cinéma magnifique donc c'est
le festival musical itinérant qui
s'appelle les jeux et c'est elena reçoit
au trianon et vous recevez donc liu
votre soeur fifi chachnil
catherine dite catherine bertrand
burgalat marie paule belle louis chedid
alain chamfort edouard baer et dorion
voilà c'est 12 et 13 février
marie paule belle elle va bien
j'aurai la voix rocher
on peut les habiter la prochaine fois
que tu seras d'accord voilà alors le 15
février ça n'arrête pas les promos pour
vous le 15 février la nuit de l'interdît
sur paris première à 23h45 spécial
petites annonces alors l'idée c'est de
provoquer des rencontres torrides et il
ya déjà eu beaucoup de nuits de
l'interdît sur sur paris première la
troisième nuit de l'interdît c'était
le 31 décembre qui s'appelait plaisir
d'offrir joie de recevoir vous en
souvenez je pense au bien et pour tous
ceux qui n'ont pas vu manh et de lozère
au sommaire de cette nuit deux interdits
un docu culotté sur l'art et la manière
de se faire botter le derrière
des images qui vous montre comment
déguster grâce à la crème fouettée c'est
le mouvement ce bloc
et des séquences inédites sur la
nouvelle pratique à la mode que art de
body art
nous enchaînerons avec un éclairage sur
les filles entre elles les ce bien
raisonnable
une série de courts métrages attachant
sur la meilleure façon de tisser des
liens le bondage
et nous nous défendrons avec une théma
paris dernière le webstore du cuir et
latex
[Musique]
mettez-moi le cul rouge maîtresse pardon
monsieur je prends tout comme moi tu me
tapes forêt mais je vais vous faire mal
à redon pardoux j'ai pu faire un très
bon été d'une part ça je le fais relais
comme ça il fallait faire idiote
[Musique]
on a de nos ados comme hommage au film
et par doris cluster la prêtresse new
yorkaise de la soumission ou célébré par
alexandre dupouy dans son anthologie
apologie voici la fessée sous toutes ses
faces de quoi prendre
et bien sûr
sur paris première et la quatrième nuit
de l'interdît en avril sera consacrée au
striptease voilà ça c'était la troisième
promo et la 4e promo c'est le 19 et 20
février les concerts à la cité de la
musique avec alain chamfort qui était
notre invité la semaine dernière
bertrand burgalat et le groupe as dragon
voilà vous avez jamais autant bossé
votre vie mais ça se voyait - ouais
c'est des fois on ça se voit là ça se
voit ces actifs est ce qui reste un
petit peu de place pour le sexe selena
oui rassurez moi ça va bien bien vous
savez que je peux être très gentil ou
très méchant je vous faire une interview
docteur jekyll et mister hyde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui lna vous êtes en train de
devenir une icône de la scène
underground c'est plutôt agréable non
ouais ça va je peux je me plains pas ça
me plaît je préfère la queue qu'ailleurs
lna thierry qui vit champs ou le fait
d'avoir été la soeur de lio ça vous a
aidé quand même oh le méchant je le suis
toujours donc si ça m'a aidé et je oui
ou non je sais pas peut-être qu on ouvre
les portes plus facilement mais quand on
est haut plus sympa mieux écouter il
faut faire ses preuves quand même on a
le sentiment elena que vous êtes trouvé
musicalement aujourd'hui
oui c'est vrai que je suis plus
confortable dans cet album
ce sont des chansons douces joué par un
trio de jazz et voilà je trouvais j'ai
trouvé les crains qu'il me fallait elena
pourquoi si peu de disques en quinze ans
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de chansons
dont je suis pas forcément fier des fois
je les réécoute je me dis c'est bien que
ce soit pas sorti non plus tu dois
t'éclater sous la douche voilà et puis
j'ai fait plein de maquettes jets privés
j'ai proposé aux maisons de disques
d'état détail de deux morceaux mais sa
pureté effacés voilà vous êtes très joli
vous adorez faire l'amour
alors pourquoi avoir choisi un mec aussi
peu sexy que
non parce que tu es marié en plus je
suis pas d'accord je trouve que c'est un
il ressemble à jim morrison
cb
news on m'a dit que je ressemblais à
jimi hendrix avec des cheveux longs oui
c'est vrai
c'est qu'une fois lna oui fait un beau
saut à
ne pas forcer c'est pas facile ce masque
en fait - et les masses
on passe à michaël blanc le nickel ton
quand vous connaissez tous les aventure
de michaël blanc jo et
un michaël blanc en taule à bali à
perpétuité mais moi je rigole pas du
shit pourquoi tu rigole mais je rigole
parce que il y avait un doute qui sont à
côté en tous les cas à perpétuité est
quand même hein comment j'ai jamais
entendu dire le régime n'est pas le même
j'ai jamais entendue qu'en france un mec
ça mais c'est vrai à perpétuité pour du
shit mais alors quoi bah alors voilà
bien médiatisé jusqu'à ta mort est ce
que tu peux m'expliquer déjà qui est
michaël blanc je sais pas au moins c'est
un mec mais c'est quand même la vraie
question quoi est-ce que
j'ai pas besoin de savoir qui les gens
c'est très bien c'est un être humain
d'un comme l'évoquait un mec même s'il a
trafiqué vraiment un kilo vite de shit
dans des bouteilles de plongée c'est pas
bien le mérite deux ans avec trois ans
ça mérite pas perpète donc ce mec là
j'ai décidé de laiton sort bien et c'est
ensemble que je m'en sors pas bien c'est
la vérité sur la proximité il ya des
vrais cas s'essaye à débreaka et que
quelqu'un qui part à ben ali et qui
délibérément charge son matou sans fin
ces accessoires deux
abandonné je pense qu'ils aient
conscience qu'il a fait je pense qu'il
n'a pas 18 ans enfin 17 ans et en 12 ans
donc ni abandonner je suis pas d'accord
quoi je pense qu'il ya des trucs
vachement plus essentielles sur la
proximité stop on passe à l'état des
enchères donc le disque d'or de coluche
offert par paul lederman 3000 euros et
c'est pascal leleu de noaillan qui tient
la corde la victoire de la musique de
johnny hallyday est à 9100 euros pour il
bon tu as de marnage le perfecto de
baffie montrent toujours il est à
6097 euros pour omar harfouch le disque
d'or de buga que les bouquins d'alsace
brendan comme un aimant le disque d'or
de buga et à
2591 euros donc ça bouge pas assez
stable depuis deux semaines mais je veux
la vraie semaine prochaine jean prat
gratuit l'ordre car il s'est vendu la
semaine prochaine tu peux venir beauvais
un peu pourri cela alors le vélo c'est
le vélo de michel drucker comme 524
euros qui est toujours en hausse pour
omar harfouch la guitare de didier
barbelivien est à 1300 euros elle sera
donc vendue la semaine prochaine parce
qu'elle ne bouge pas à la gemme patients
la guitare de la le costume de lagaf est
à 200 euros yves gauthier de gap veulent
acheter les rôles r&d taïg khris le
champion du monde sont 1 200 euros
stable et voilà moi regarde en fait
verger faire ça
je me donnais mon t-shirt vidéo s
il y en a aucun
c'est exercer un prototype mais je vais
le donner c'est à dire mais je n'ai donc
pas pour la personne qui quoi en fait
pour les gens se présentent pour les
gens qui quittent quand même un bout de
conscience et qu'ils sont dans ton
histoire en se disant voilà la suit il
n'y avait pas perpétuité donc tac tac
mais en espérant que ces gens là aussi
ils feront un geste en cas où il faut se
lever pour dire que la préventive céda
merde
voilà je mets mon maillot madame attaque
mais je vais le mettre je voulais être
dans un endroit particulier
monsieur
le ciel
michaud
[Musique]
un passant l'a toujours
- paris françois
toi aussi tu
acheter
ça va parler ça va
ça va j'ai assez mal dans le hip hop
parce qu'on est très
bien on continue sur michaël blanc ml de
maele de lille qui dit pour le mic hel
ton j'offre ma virginité est ce que ça
marche non
non ce qui pourrait marcher pour michaël
blanc c'est une action de la france en
la personne du président de la
république jacques chirac c'est ce qui
marcherait le mieux pour sortir michaël
blanc de son trou voilà
mesdames messieurs j'accueille
maintenant avec sandrine herman
[Musique]
voir
alex le german bonsoir vous êtes le fils
de paul lederman qui était l'imprésario
de michel polnareff de thierry le luron
de coluche des inconnus et maintenant
d'aïoli voilà et vous avez participé à
la création des restos du coeur
les comme vous avez trouvé la cause
finalement un petit peu hexagonal vous
avez décidé de vous intéresser au sort
du monde alors vous ai déjà publié deux
ouvrages en 1999 le capital du coeur qui
traitait de l'exclusion et de la
richesse chez robert laffont et en 2002
vous publiez le futur était presque
parfait au cherche midi éditeur vous
savez comment on fait attention
y'a quoi dans ce bouquin
il ya pas mal de choses sur le monde
entier pas mal de choses sur la
mondialisation franche est née sur ce
qu'on disait avant j'ai eu hier josé
bové au téléphone parce qu'en parlant de
prison il vient d'être condamné bon
c'est un peu un scandale il faut le
soutenir on est nombreux à le soutenir
des fonds il en a lui pas vraiment
besoin puisque il est très très soutenu
par les états unis des agriculteurs des
états unis lui envoie de l'argent par
par internet il est mais là ça montre
bien vraiment le clivage entre deux
sociétés
là une société qui qui qui a du mal à
vivre les crises au jour le jour et puis
ce qu'on appelle les maîtres du monde
qui viennent de se réunir à davos j'ai
eu l'occasion dans mon enquête de faire
les deux et donc là aujourd'hui ce que
j'essaie de dire dans ce livre c'est
qu'il faut vraiment établir un dialogue
vraiment entre entre ces deux mondes qui
ont du mal à connecter si on peut dire
et c'est ma thèse centrale soit
aujourd'hui les ce qu'on appelle
maintenant communément les maîtres du
monde accepte de dialoguer avec avec
porto allègre avec avec josé de des
pauvres avec les pauvres enfin avec ce
pas mal de gens qui ont plein d'idées ou
alors ça sera l'explosion alors y'a pas
que les pauvres puisque maintenant il ya
des gens des prix nobel d'économie il ya
des lobbies de washington qui ont
rejoint la cause des anti mondialiste
donc ça commence à se structurer ça
commence à parler d'égal à égal c'est un
peu nouveau très bien alors vous est
passé près d'un an et demi à parcourir
le monde itélé seattle à davos à pékin à
new york à barcelone à singapour à la
rencontre des acteurs de la
mondialisation
et pour expliquer la mondialisation on
devine même etc dot qui est celle du jus
d'orange et scoop et nous la poule à
dire oui alors c'est à dire c'était à
seattle seattle c'était un peu
surprenante on arrive pour participer à
un sommet et puis en plus dans mon cas
j'avais pris l'avion j'avais pas encore
mon accréditation donc je me suis
débrouillé sur place et puis on arrive
on mais c'était carrément la révolution
les manifestations les mâles et les
bombes lacrymogènes enfin c'était les
policiers qui tiraient les petites
balles en caoutchouc et carrément le
finalement le les colocs pouvait pas
avoir lieu alors on se retrouve dans un
café dans un cybercafé plus exactement
mais les téléphones portables passé pas
plus rien et est connecté alors comment
ils étaient un peu sous le décalage
horaire je commande un jus d'orange en
étaient une quinzaine avec il y avait
des singapouriens il y avait du monde
entier les journalistes du monde entier
et alors ils arrivent avec un jus
lyophilisés oui ça c'est dégueulasse
voudriez pas quelque chose d'un peu plus
c'est plus proche de l' orange et il
revient avec un autre jus d'orange il me
dit mais ça a été c'est très connu parce
qu'à la télévision on voit les
publicités de ce jus d'orange qui
sponsorisait par les grandes équipes de
basket week-end ça vient d'une
exploitation californienne modèle c'est
formidable alors je lui dis bon cela me
convient pas non plus je suis obligé de
l'umih mais c'est vraiment long range le
vrai fruit qui m'intéressent alors le
type me dis là ça quand même fait marrer
tout le monde si c'était pour des
raisons médicales il fallait me prévus
c'est un peu ça aussi la mondialisation
croyant plus l'addition 10 $ l'oranje
c'était un peu cher c'est plus cher
qu'une veuve range alors vous êtes
intéressé aussi par les biotechnologies
vous dit
l'alchimiste de l'avenir c'est le
jongleur de gênes oui c'est à dire que
je en fait c'est un livre où j'essaie de
mettre en garde sur les dangers de la
mondialisation
c'est une approche un peu pédagogique et
jeux à la à la fin de mon ouvrage
les deux parties qui sont assez
percutante une sur ce que j'appelle les
alchimistes de l'avenir c'est ce qu'ils
veulent modifier notre adn c'est le
problème du clonage des organismes
génétiquement modifiés non c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui qui portent atteinte à
notre être mais en même temps qui est un
progrès extraordinaire en laboratoire et
peut-être pour l'avenir de l'humanité
mais enfin on est quand même plus proche
de brave new world 1 et d'une société un
peu de metropolis de fritz lang plutôt
que dans une mondialisation heureuse
voilà alexandre est normal vu sur était
presque parfait enquête sur la
mobilisation cette recherche me dit en a
b c
alors mesdames messieurs on va passer au
blind test mais avant je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire que pour jouer au
blind test sans attendre le samedi il
suffit d'avoir un doigt ou une oreille
et un téléphone doit je n'aurais h
téléphone cette semaine il y avait dix
cdd stone a gagné et le gagnant est joël
le floch se poullaouen dans le finistère
la semaine prochaine il ya un coffret de
32 cdd doit gagner plus décédé voilà
cinquante double cd collector de legend
de bob marley franchement c'est pas de
la merde
m
et
relâché au blind test en blind test
spécial héroïne de chanson ce soir et
pour arbitrer le blind j'appelle mon
cher philippe corti
à
ghana quinqua pas moufté quand il ya eu
des coups de feu c'est joey starr il n'a
pas bougé d'un millimètre on était tous
comme ça et lui l'a pas branché d'un
millimètre voilà
c'est pas ça alors on gagne quoi
philippe faux soir alors puisque c'est
en oui mais qu' on est un peu dans
l'esprit tombera énorme affaire jungle
ouais des serpents itunes est alors on
gagne des serpents contre les araignées
d'accord ce gars
évidemment si un soufflage ya des
habillages tout le monde le sait
évidemment
tagliani j'ai une question non non les
mecs c'est toutes les semaines
maintenant ouais assez bien je trouve cc
comment la parité je suis un lecteur je
suis l'objet objets au moins
tallieu hausse initiale et des habits et
ici aussi soufflé des avis de retard
mais c'est vrai
blind test spécial héroïne de la chanson
ce soir je veux joey starr ne dit pas
après que vous ne saviez pas les règles
du jeu je veux à dès qu'ils voient un
gain c'est pas possible
il est plutôt les 6 35 d'habitude bon
alors joey starr ne dit pas après vous
ne connaissiez pas les règles je veux le
nom du chanteur de la chanteuse c'est
tout ce que je veux d'accord
le thème ses héroïnes de chansons à
baiona allons-y tu m'aurais didier
une question est ce que talia vous
pouvez allez vous asseoir sur l'escalier
là bas s'il vous plaît
je sais que le parti pris moi
personnellement je n'ai entendu sur fait
c'est la rage bien talia vous restez là
bas vous êtes comme on dit au piquet
je m'en fout vraiment cool
de vous arrêter
vous avez été
bien bon didier
j'arrive ici m6 m6 solex ouais ça
s'arrête même si cela peut sembler une
blague
c'est un peu bouge de là
le thème seconde de 500 comptes à
ok ça le thème canadien simulé
ça va
à
je tenais à dire que vous n'êtes que des
merdes
non mais il le score c'est quoi ces 3,3
pour les mygales et 0 0
fais gaffe leur vie regarder l'avenir le
dira le rebelle rend elle réussit elle
souffle pas fait les belles robes
chemisiers
sega bravo
je crois je crois qu'on va reprendre la
gonzesse qui souffrent parce que son
ballon
jody carr titia titien est une sainte
c'est la faute
aux pas le prendre parce qu'elle souffre
le parce qu'elles savent où est ce
qu'elle soit parce qu'elles ont l'une
jamie peux pas croire qu'elle est minée
sinon il ya un problème dans la
production
passe comme ça et voilà oui alors que
linda linda hardy à souffler parce que
les fifa a été bien apprécié des gens
n'est pas restée l est pas et c'est cela
didier
ricky
je joue
m
serge un petit replay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok on va souffler on voit bien
je sais que c'était les beatles alors
maintenant je vais dire une chose finir
la semaine prochaine dont j'ai pris une
grave décision la semaine prochaine vous
ne serez plus arbitres phillies ont dit
parce que vous êtes trop de partis pris
des otages
clint trop de participants caviar et la
semaine prochaine sur un huissier ici
sur ce plateau se veut mettre bakchich
voilà j'ai décidé je rêvais bakchich ici
on verra ce que vous faites philippe le
trop de parti-pris pontallier didier
réseau
[Musique]
qui sait non
saillant
non
[Musique]
alors un point pour vous
malgré la souffleuse et 11 ans
didier
[Musique]
g
un des meilleurs meneurs
les stars
[Applaudissements]
normal parce qu'elles viennent on va sur
l'escale de base sur l'escalier parce
que maintenant quand elle dit mick
jagger tu dis non en lice non j'ai pas
dit ça sur l'escalier de la semaine
prochaine et annie sié je peux plus
je ne peux plus travailler là je suis
content ici arrêté je sais toi aussi bon
on continue
c'est terrible à ce qui se passe ce soir
c'est à dire que l'arbitré de parti pris
et philippe mais oui
[Musique]
les ai jury dario moreno
serge khalfon effectivement elena dit
dario
cendrier
voir son 126e ri
non
michel
viviez
à l'histoire
raymond souplex
appel si je gagne parce que j'ai fait
comme ça
raymond souplex très bon souple est non
jeunes sourds ça mais je suis le petit
fils de raymond souplex un jour quand
c'est vrai
le china
tibet tabriquet est-ce que tu connais
serge et la lna messieurs
m
[__]
joey starr connu annie cordy jeu couple
marié avec elle a laissé inchangé à ma
vie ça fait vachement bien attention
didier
[Musique]
aux
attentions ont tout face j'attendais non
non attendez attendez
attendez attendez attendez maintenant de
toute façon l'équipe qui va remporter le
super banco et nous va remporter la
partie donc tout ça c'était du flan
didier
[Musique]
m
oui mais
après le super banco vial hiver mon père
pasqua
attention lippi revanche quand didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah oui j la je vois
aucun
alors
banana non non non non après le repos on
vient de maxi manteau
le maximum didier
leschi l'aéroport et maxi rococo
non
[Applaudissements]
elle
marie laforêt n'a pas remporté car après
le maxi banco ya le muguet bancaire
dj
c'est trop tard
paul le guen obama
et
[Applaudissements]
abo
damien thiéry y'a pas un oui vous avez
bien voilà bravo bravo bravo
et voilà
[Musique]
voilà c'était souvent d'antan l'émission
pas comme les autres laurent baffie sexe
magouille et culture générale
je lance ma fille au théâtre de la
renaissance
alain prost merci d'être venu vous
exprimer dans tout le monde en parle
elisa tovati son single s'appelle moi je
t'aime pour ya thierry merci joey starr
le single
bien joué
la marie laforêt merci d'avoir choisi
tout le monde en parle de vous exprimer
comme après 122 toile dans toute la
france il termine à marseille les 22 et
23 mars voilà genève est hs et le dvd du
spectacle
françois léotard la couleur des femmes
chez grasset voilà helena noguerra leur
elena reçoit au trianon le 12 et 13
février le festival musical les jeux
l'album s'appelle azoul les nuits gains
termine sur paris première le 15 février
à 23h45 alexandre ledermann
le plus dur était presque parfait aux
éditions du cherche midi et philippe
corti vivent à la feria corti
non
[Musique]
m
jamais
[Musique]
oui
tu sais pas
m
g
têtu
[Musique]
moi
non
on
sa mère
non
[Musique]
no
nous
non
sa mère
on a
[Musique]
non
m
oh
non
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus